[Musique]
marcti bonsoir bonsoir Sky bonsoir à
toutes et à tous et ravi d'être parmi
vous ce soir nous vous recevons pour une
chaîne internet qui s'appelle Serview
nous sommes en direct est-ce que vous
pouvez vous présenter succeintement
alors ben écoute avec plaisir donc donc
je suis un enfant des cité HLM dorly
voilà donc j'ai vécu de 0 à 24 ans et
après j'ai commencé ma carrière comme
enseignant chercheur à l'Université
Paris en pantéon Sorbonne j'ai fais
comme des études d'économie et de
finances avant hein et donc j'ai voilà
commencé ma carrière à la pantéon
Sorbonne après j'ai cré l'études
économique à la Banque Populaire donc en
97 j'avais 27 ans à l'époque j'étais le
plus jeune chef économiste de de banque
je crois que j'ai mon record n'a pas été
battu d'ailleurs depuis et savez que
j'ai été c'était ma volonté à l'époque
d'essayer de démocratiser l'économie
parce qu'à l'époque l'économie cétait
c'est un petit peu abscon hein les
économistes voilà souvent il y en a
d'ailleurs un d'entre eux on va pas
donner de nom et qui me disait Marc il y
a un problème avec toi on te comprends
trop quand tu parles voilà et pour moi
c'était en fait je dirais une grande
qualité entre guillemets et donc c'est
vrai que j'ai essayé de faire ça et ça
ça a très bien fonctionn donc voilà donc
j'ai cré l'éudes économique à la Banque
Populaire et puis donc en 97 c'était
important parce que j'ai fais ma
première télé c'était pas du tout prévu
sur LCI à l'époque c'était la la seule
chaîne info et donc je me rappelle en
sortir de l'émission euh c'était sur la
crise asiatique à l'époque de 97 fin
d'année donc Jean-Claude dassciier qui
était le président de directeur général
de de LCI me dit c'est la première fois
que j'écoute un économiste et je
comprends ce qu'il dit donc on va vous
réinviter plus souvent voilà et ça a
commencé comme ça et donc ça a très bien
marché voilà donc mon service a grossi
après c'est devenu Nexis Banque
Populaire voilà donc tout tout allait
très bien et puis en 2006 2007 il y a
une autre fusion qui s'est pas très bien
passé donc je dis bon allez c'est le
moment pour moi de de de quitter j'avais
plus parce que vra j'avais une chance
très très très forte à l'époque c'est
que j'avais une liberté de parole
complète ce qui était très rare et donc
c'est j'avais le président des Banques
populaires qui me soutenait en
permanence il y avait énormément de
pression contre moi déjà à l'époque et
pourtant il dis NON NON si on a un
économiste c'est pour qu'il disent la
vérité pour qu'il disent les choses et
donc c'est vrai que ça ça ça a bien
fonctionné puis en 2007 ça a commencé à
changer donc là je suis parti et donc
j'ai créé mon cabinet donc à ces défi au
commande de l'économie et de la finance
et donc c'est vrai que voilà depuis je
je suis indépendant alors j'ai eu des
clients Global Equities et cetera
d'autres des aujourd'hui la plupart des
banques également compag d'assurance et
fait un peu tout le monde vaiton dire je
fais des conférences des séminaires et
je conseille les entreprises bien
entendu et et donc voilà c'était un
petit peu le but et donc plus
dernièrement j'ai créé ma chaîne youtube
effectivement pendant le coronavirus
parce qu'on était enfermé comme vous le
savez donc je saais pas que donc les
télé m'appelé mais comme j'étais pas en
France parce que j'avais pas envie de
d'être là donc je pouvais pas aller donc
je dis bon je vais créer ma chaîne
Youtube c'est mes enfants d'ailleurs qui
m'ont un petit peu pris le challenge ils
m'ont dit tu pourras pas le faire tout
donc je dis bon on va on va essayer et
c'est vrai que ça ça a bien fonctionné
donc voilà on est à presque 120000
abonnés aujourd'hui donc d'ailleurs je
pour les remercier et et c'est vrai que
c'est c'est important on va dire de je
pense de de dire de dire les choses qu'
en fait c'est vrai que les économistes
trop bon ils peuvent parler mais je dis
c'est comme les hommes politiques on
peut pas vérifier de ce qu'ils disent
moi tout ce que je dis dans ma chaîne
notamment je le montre donc avec des
graphiques réalisés sans trucage donc
c'est important de visualiser parce que
quand on ne visualise pas très vite on a
peur et donc quand on a peur bah on est
bloqué on invvestit plus on ose plus
innover prendre des risques et cetera or
c'est les crises font partie de la vie
économique don sou ça somme d'ailleurs
ça me déplaî un peu on me dépint comme
comme pessimiste je suis pas du tout
pessimiste je suis au contraire de
nature extrêmement optimiste mais je
pense qu'il faut aussi être réaliste que
quand on est réaliste justement on peut
réagir en conséquence et bien comprendre
que les crises sont des phases
d'opportunité par contre si on les a pas
vu venir ou si on est dans le dénis de
réalité là on est sûr de se planter donc
c'est c'est un petit peu voilà un petit
peu mon but et je pense qu'il y a un
vrai besoin sachant que on a une culture
économique qui malheureusement est assez
faible en France où elle est galvodée ou
elle est politisée on a une culture de
lutte des classes hein je le dis souvent
c'est malheureusement donc je pense
qu'on peut dire des choses aujourd'hui
tout simplement alors des fois on me dit
ah non mais ça c'est vous êtes libéral
vous êtes ça le fait de dire par exemple
qu'il a une dette publique aujourd'hui à
presque 3100 milliards d'euros en France
on dire ça c'est libéral mais c'est pas
libéral de dire ça c'est une réalité
tout simplement donc voilà on aime bien
cataloguer on aime bien mettre des
étiquettes moi je pense qu'aujourd'hui
on a la France est en danger
économiquement parlant pas que
économiquement parlant également
socialement d'un point de vue sociétal
aussi et et donc c'est vrai que c'est
important et et j'en parle d'autant
mieux j'ai envie de dire que moi j'ai
connu l'adversité entre guillemets c'est
vrai que bon même si j'ai j'ai jamais
mangé dans la rue fort heureusement mais
je veux dire c'est il y avait des des
fin de mois difficiles parfois pour mes
pour mes parents et et donc voilà je
sais ce que c'est dans le CIT HLM mais à
l'époque c'est vrai qu'il y avait une
certaine une certaine certain solidarité
un certain honneur j'ai envie dire un
certain code d'honneur qu'on j'ai
l'impression qu'on a plus forcément
aujourd'hui et j'ai réussi à m'en sortir
donc c'est vrai grâce à mes parents je
maintenant ils sont plus là
malheureusement mais c'est vrai que ça a
été une grande chance pour moi de
d'avoir leur soutien quoi qu'il arrive
quoi qu'il en coûte parce que ça leur
coûtait également bon j'ai eu une bourse
et cetera j'ai pu étudier c'est sûr donc
merci également la France parce queà on
dénigre aussi trop souvent là aussi la
France on oublie que la France c'est un
pays qui est formidable nous sommes
numéro 1 du monde en terme de dépense
social c'est 32 % de notre PIB peut-être
c'est peut-être beaucoup mais c'est vrai
que parfois c'est gaspillé mais
néanmoins moi j'en ai bénéficié donc
c'est important ces dépenses social mais
quand je vois aujourd'hui mes cités HLM
je suis retourné à or il y a pas très
longtemps d'ailleurs ma cité où j'étais
s'appelle ça s'appelle les SAS et c'est
devenu je crois une des plaques
tournantes de trafic de drogue
maintenant donc c'est c'est assez c'est
encore plus dangereux quand moi j'ai été
avant c'était les Combas de pitbou euh
voilà bon il y avait des il y avait des
cités je me rappelle dès qu'il faisait
nuit il fallait pas y aller si on était
pas du si on habitait pas sur place on
pouvait pas y aller euh mais bon c'est
c'est c'est la vie on va dire mais il y
avait quand même jeis puis il y avait
surtout une volonté de s'en sortir
honnêtement j'ai envie de dire le drame
aujourd'hui c'est qu'on a un taux de
chômage dans les cité HLM un taux de
chômage des moins de 25 ans de 60 %. je
vais vous demander à chaque fois vos
chiffres vos sources on a décidé de vous
faire venir aujourd'hui parce que nous
on aime bien votre boulot sur Internet
vous faites partie du YouTube game comme
on dit c'est gentil et vous vous me
faites gagner du temps parce que
votreevue votre chronique sur votre
chaîne Youtube je je deviens un peu
fénéant c'està-dire que avant c'est moi
je le faisais à la main ce que vous
faites et et et maintenant je l'ai tout
cuit grâce à vous c'est sourcé à l'écran
c'est daté à l'écran c'est des sources
carrés cubiques euh pas des sources de
bruit de couloir ah non non il faut
toujours donner les vraies sources et
c'est pour ça c'est pour ça que je je me
fais un malin plaisir de venir vous
écouter au moins une à deux fois par moi
et je recommande ma communauté je je
recommande votre chaîne Youtube parce
que c'est vraiment euh comme je j'aimis
le dire carré et
cubique c'est le but mais je pense c'est
important encore une fois de dire les
choses et bien sûr je mets les sources
bien entendu c'est toujours des sources
officielles soit l'INC le FMI l'OCDE et
cetera parce qu'encore une fois on ne
peut pas encore une fois mentir on peut
pas on n pas le droit aujourd'hui on se
doit et c'est le problème de nos
politiques on se doit de dire la vérité
au français donc on a on a on vous a
fait venir pour ça que vous reformuliez
votre prospective après avoir fait une
analyse les mains dans le camboui en
allant chercher les chiffres en croisant
les chiffres et peut-être en
interprétant les chiffres alors ça c'est
c'est important aussi c'estàdire que moi
je j'ai jamais voulu être un économiste
de salon entre guillemets les écomist de
salon y a que ça quasiment en France
voilà qui donnent des conseils mais qui
nont jamais été sur le terrain entre
guillemets voilà ça me fait rire quand
je vois certains écomistes m' pas donner
le nom parce que faut pas être méchant
mais qui parl des marchés financiers ils
n'ont jamais mis les pieds dans une
salle de marché c'est c'est incroyable
ou qui parlent de l'entreprise savent
pas comment fonctionne je dirais une
entreprise ou autre et ça c'est c'est
plus possible donc moi j'ai toujours
justement et ça c'était une des force
que j'ai eu une des chances que j'ai eu
d'aller quand j'étais au banqu populaire
notamment d'aller voir d'avoir les mains
dans le camboui d'aller voir les les
chefs d'entreprise je le fais toujours
aujourd'hui d'aller faire les chef
d'entreprise les particulier également
quand je fais des conférences autour de
l'épargne et autres ça c'est important
et c'est très très important pour moi
parce que quand je fais mes conférences
après il y a des questions questions
réponse et très souvent j'ai des idées
de d'articles des idées de de chroniques
de vidéo au travers de ces questions
parce que s'ils ont ces ces questions
c'est qu'il y a justement une
préoccupation importante et qu'on se
doit de répondre justement à ces
question et ça c'est encore une fois
très important là moi je pense que on
doit être dans la réalité et très
souvent je pense on peut le dire parce
que quand on fait des prévisions
économiques bon il y a une partie on va
dire des anticipations des anticipations
tout à fait il y a une partie on va dire
d'équation de modèle mathématique de de
de corrélation graphique et cetera donc
aussi une perception du réel exactement
il a il y a surtout un contact avec le
terrain et ça c'est extrêmement
important et je donne souvent bon il y a
plusieurs exemples c'est sûr mais parce
qu'on souvent parfois on perçoit comme
pessimiste mais alors pour les plus
anciens j'ai commencé à me faire
connaître en fait en 98 à l'époque
j'avais créé un indicateur avancé de
l'économie française et et donc à
l'époque je disais la croissance elle
est sous-estimée par l'INC voyez c'est
l'inverse d'aujourd'hui parce que en
fait fait on avait beaucoup de création
d'emploi par rapport à l'économie et je
disais pourquoi parce que justement on
n'intègre pas à l'époque ce qui
s'appelait la nouvelle économie c'est
dire toutes les les créations de
richesse d'emploi de la révolution
Internet comme on l'appelait à l'époque
et c'est vrai que donc j'avais annoncé
que Linc sous-estimé le PIB de l'ordre
de 1 point à l'épque peut-être fait
exprès en terme de guerre économique
alors peut-être mais c'est vrai qu'à
l'époque ça avait fait un toet et cetera
98 on était encore sur le front il
fallait que le front reste compétitif
aussi il y avait il y avait ça aussi
mais surtout je pense qu'il y avait un
problème de de compéten he tout
simplement mais il y a beaucoup
d'économistes qui m'ont sauté dessus et
je me rappelle il y avait le à l'époque
il y avait le journal qui s'appelait le
Nouvel Économiste c'est un magazine qui
existe d'ailleurs toujours mais
maintenant il est plus je crois sous
forme papier et donc il avait fait les
économistes qui compent en France il y
en avait huit et donc il y avait que des
gens d'un certain âge on va dire de mon
âge actuel et moi j'étais le seul jeune
quoi j'avais donc 20 27 28 ans vous avez
là maintenant j'ai 53 bientôt 54 fa pas
ah c'est gentil merci beaucoup B on
essaie de rester jeune il faut je suis
même grand-père vous rendez compte donc
c'est pour vous dire depuis peu depis
peu merci beaucoup merci beaucoup et euh
à la maman oui tout à fait bien c'est ma
fille la maman c'est ma fille exactement
et euh donc ce que je dire pas là c'est
que et et et à partir de là et lincé
ensuite donc un an plus tard a révisé
ces chiffres en disant oui effectivement
il manque 1,5 points à la croissance VO
donc et ça je l'ai je l'ai je l'ai capté
entre guillemets grâce à mon contact
avec le terrain et très souvent quand on
fait ses prévisions sur l'économie parle
dernièrement ces anticipations
anticipation ok très bien euh là
dernièrement moi je disais voilà il va
avoir une récession en France et même
runur m'a dit Marc arrêz il y a pas de
récession tout va bien et cetera bon
alors on a pour le faire on a des
indicateurs avancés ce qu'on appelle les
indicateurs des directeur d'achat
notamment donc ça c'est très simple à
comprendre he il y a une barre à 50
au-dessus c'est la croissance de
l'activité en dessus c'est le recu de
l'activité depuis le mois de juin
dernier en France on est sous les 50
pour l'ensemble des secteurs d'activité
et là même on est à 44,6 ENF on est
extrêmement bas si vous voulez on est
même parmi les plus bas du monde rendez
compte en terme d'activité selon les
directeurs d'achat donc c'est pas moi
qui l'ai inventé c'est de réalité et en
plus quand je vais sur le terrain
justement voir les chefs d'entreprise
ils me disent queil y en a un gros
problème aujourd'hui économique et donc
voilà pourquoi j'aiannoncé cette
récession et maintenant Bruno Lemer on
l'a vu cette semaine il a dit oui
effectivement il y aura moins de
croissance il a révisé de 1,4 % à 1 % de
croissance je pense même qu'on pourrait
faire 0,5 % de croissance en 2024 donc
c'est quand même c'est pas génial et
donc ça aussi ça vient dirit du concret
donc c'est ça le problème on a besoin
d'avoir les mains dans le cou d'être
dans le concret voyez quand on voit les
chiffres des défaillances d'entreprises
qui sont sur un plus haut aujourd'hui en
France depuis 2017 et si vous enlever ce
qu'on appelle les micro-entreprises donc
c'est on garde les vra les entreprises
qui créent vraiment des emplois on est
sur un plus haut depuis
2010 vous rendez compte donc il y a un
problème attention les défaillances sont
sont très importantes et s'il y a des
défaillances d'entreprise donc ça veut
dire des faillites à ce momentlà il y a
des licenciement donc le chômage qui a
déjà commencé à augmenter va continuer
d'augmenter donc ça c'est notre devoir à
nous les les économistes de le dire de
prévenir les économistes qui sirent les
pompes en disant non mais tout va bien
Monsieur le Maire vous inquiétez pas
c'est parfait moi je les ai vu hein j'ai
j'ai été pendant notamment le
coronavirus en en en 2020 pour n m nous
avait contacté donc m'avais invité j'y
suis allé alors c'est vrai qu'au début
du du corona en mars 20020 on cya que
c'était la fin du monde bon quand ils
nous ont annoncé qu'ils allaient fermer
le monde la France qu'ils allaient donc
faire le quoi qu'il en coûte bon moi
j'étais pas très chaud mais bon je dis
bon si c'est la fin du monde à la
rigueur au diable Avaris heureusement ça
NAA pas été hein et mais donc fin 2020
début 2021 je je je commence à dire
écoutez là maintenant il faut arrêter
quoi qu'il en coûte il faut arrêter
d'augmenter la dette publique et là on
est sauté dessus on va sauté dessus
alors pas physiquement bien sûr mais
tous les économistes ont dit mais non
mais on s'en fout de la dette c'est pas
grave c'est la BCE qui qui achète cette
dette les taux d'intérêts n'augmenteront
jamais voilà le discours que j'avais à
l'époque qui était complètement
irresponsable et on le voit aujourd'hui
les taux d'intérêt évidemment sont
remontés tout à fait logiquement
d'ailleurs cette planche habillée cette
dette publique a créé en partie
l'inflation ne l'oublions pas
l'inflation n'est pas née avec la guerre
en Ukraine l'inflation elle a commencé
en 2021 pourquoi parce que c'est l'une
des règles de base de l'économie on a
créé plus de demandes donc artificiell
par rapport à l'offre à la fameuse
planche à Bill ça c'est vux comme le
monde quand on crée trop de monnaie par
rapport à la réalité économique bah
l'inflation les prix augmentent c'est
logique vous voyez ce que je veux dire
et d'ailleurs c'est ça c'est la force de
l'économie parce que savez l'économie je
dis souvent c'est une science humaine ça
veut dire c'est pas les mathématiques où
voilà on a des des règles claires ça
veut dire la évolue avec le temps donc
ce qui était vrai il y a il y a 5 ans 10
ans est pas forcément aujourd'hui elle
sera pas forcément dans 10 ans par
contre il y a des règles de base qui ne
qui ne change jamais et parmi ces règles
de base il y en a plusieurs il y en
seulement celle-ci qui est que bah
l'offre et la demande vous créer trop de
demande par rapport à l'offre les prix
ont tendance à augmenter c'est
exactement ce qu'on a fait alors au
début je dis pas ok mars 2020 c'était la
panique mais après ce qu'on attend de
nos responsable c'est de dire bon
attendez on va calmer le jeu on va
arrêter cette fuite en avant et on va
anticiper justement et malheureusement
ce n'a pas ça n'a pas été le cas et on a
continué la fuite en avant jusqu'à
encore très peu de temps et donc on le
voit aujourd'hui les taux d'intérêt ont
explosé si bien que parce que ça aussi
c'est une grande arnaque on on nous dit
souvent la dette publique ne nous coûte
rien depuis l'année dernière vous savez
c'est combien chaque année la charge
d'intérêt de la dette dernière c'était
49 milliards d'euros hein donc 2000 en
2023 cette année ça va être pareil
peut-être même un peu plus 50 et Bercy
lui-même c'està dire le ministère de des
finances lui-même sur des prévisions
optimistes annonce qu'à partir de 2027
ça sera 74 milliards d'euros par an
juste de charge d'intérêt de la dette
donc j'ai fait un petit calcul très
simple en 5 ans ça veut dire que la
charge d'intérêt de la dette encore une
fois juste les intérêts de la dette les
Agou voilà en quelque sorte ça a coûté
tenez-vous bien
295 milliards d'euros c'est pas sérieux
depuis 2000 ça a coûté
1350 milliards d'euros B c'est des
sommes complètement folle c'estd que
quand on me dit aujourd'hui que la dette
ne nous coûte rien que c'est nos enfants
qui vont payer alors déjà c'est pas
sympa pour nos enfants mais c'est faux
on commence d'ors et déjà à payer et et
et on paye par une réduction de service
public on paye par ben on paye parce que
évidemment il y a ces milliards qui
tombent pas du ciel alors aujourd'hui on
dit mais c'est pas grave tant que la
dette française s'achète sur les marchés
tant que effectivement des investisseurs
achètent cette dette et donc tout va
bien oui mais quand quand quand ils
achètent la dette indexée sur
l'inflation ah bah ça c'est encore pire
évidemment ça ça c'est un des produits
he d'ailleurs qui que j'ai conseillé sur
ma chaîne youtube je sais pas si vous
avez ça on donne PAS de conseil
financiers ici atttion d' non mais non
mais je je donne pas mais ce que dire
c'est moi je l'avais fait parce que
c'était sur ma chaîne je me permettrai
pas ici mais j'avais dit à l'époque
écoutez il y a un super produit que
j'avais été l'un des premiers à annoncer
l'augmentation de l'inflation là aussi
effectivement on rayonné moi je l'avais
mis dans mon dernier livre reset 2
notamment et c'est vrai qu'à l'époque on
me disait mais non l'inflation c'est
fini il y aura plus jamais d'inflation
et donc j'avais j'avais dit ben comme
l'inflation va augmenter si vous achetez
des obligations d'État indexé sur
l'inflation ça veut dire que votre
rendement va augmenter avec l'inflation
c'est une super affaire donc c'est ce
qui s'est produit donc pour ceux qui ont
acheté c'est très bien par contre pour
l'État évidemment c'est un coût
supplémentaire à votre avis pourquoi
l'État a émis ses oat index sur
l'inflation ça a toujours existé ENF ça
fait des années que ça existe une
vingtaine d'années que ça existe à peu
prèsil Savit pas qu'il y avait de
l'inflation qui arrivait ou il comp sur
une déflation globalement comme le
produit existait déjà quand il y avait
pas d'inflation donc c'est tout tout BF
guillemets et je pense qu'il y a eu une
erreur de de diagnostic c'est une erreur
où c'était pour
euh comme un un petit doping c'était un
peu de la de l'adrénaline pour les
banques c'est-à-dire sinon on n'arrivait
pas àourier notre dette oui en partie
mais c'est vrai que c'est intéressant en
disant voilà là il y a un petit bonus
avec l'inflation donc c'est vrai que
c'est toujours intéressant he de se dire
le le taux d'intérêt donc va suivre
l'inflation ça a toujours moi j'ai ça a
toujours été intéressant mais je pense
que il n'avait pas anticipé une aussi
forte augmentation de l'inflation alors
euh on on va parler de notre ami le
ministère des Finances parce que Bruno
lomè en fin de compte c'est simplement
la tête de gondol on n pas l'impression
qui qui qui comprend grand-chose votre
perception de Bruno lomè c'est parce
qu'il fait de la communication damage
contrô c'est-à-dire qu'il évite de faire
peur aux gens il essaie de propager la
confiance il essaie de galvaniser les
foules où il y panne rien et il est mal
conseillé moi je l' rencontré plusieurs
fois moi je pense que au fond de lui
c'est quelqu'un de bien c'est
globalement il a envie effectivement de
faire de faire des choses mais il est
bloqué par qui B audessus de lui c'est
qui audessus jeallais dire Bruno Macron
Emmanuel Macron évidemment c'estàd que
Macron pourquoi il est bloqué bah je
pense que le problème si vous voulez il
est très simple c'est qu'il faut une
volonté politique un courage politique
de moderniser l'économie française et
notamment pour la moderniser c'est pas
compliqué il faudra c'est dur à entendre
mais il faut dire il faudra réduire la
dépense publique nous sommes numéro 1 du
monde en terme de dépense publique on
est à 58,5 % de notre PIB de dépenses
publiques ça ça un coup donc on est
numéro 1 du monde avant on avait les
pays de scandinav du nord de l'Europe où
il faisaient plus que nous maintenant on
les a dépassés il y a quelques petites
îles dans le Pacifique qui font plus que
nous mais bon c'est un petit peu
artificiel mais tout ça pour dire que à
la rigueur si ça marchait c'estd si ça
fonctionnait oui c'estd si on avait je
peux vous couper allez-y oui bien sûr ça
fonctionne on a on achète la paix
sociale alors non mais c'est ce que
j'allais dire un petit peu par-ci un
petit peu par là ça fait penser vous
savez ou souverain qui se balade dans la
rue qui pioche dans sa poche et qui fait
tiens Marau tiens maant alors je vais
vous dire très honnêtement moi j'ai
rencontré tous les présidents Premier
ministre mise l'économist que vous
voulez depuis des années et et j'ai
toujours ce discours que vous venez n
dire là c'està dire quand je leur disais
bon bah là les gars enfin je leur disais
pas les gars mais je dis messieur est-ce
il faut baisser un petit peu euh la
dépense public à l'époque c'était facile
on était à 52 % du PIB je dis il faut
baisser à 50 bon c'est 50 c'est logique
il me disait ah ben non euh moi je veux
la paix sociale VO donc c'était
l'argument donc à la rigueur si ça
marche je dis au diable Avaris c'est de
la paix sociale ou c'est de la
subordnation de vote bon c'est c'est un
c'est un peu les deux mais mais
globalement le problème c'est
qu'aujourd'hui ça marche plus pourquoi
ça marche plus ben parce que
malheureusement je vais vous donner un
chiffre très simple alors sourcz et tout
hein sourcz lin lin tous mes chiffres
sont officiels ils viennent de l'INC
notamment donc vous pouvez aller les
voir sur le chiffre de le site de l'INC
je dis à chaque fois parce que encore
cette semaine là quelqu'un m'a dit oui
mais vos chiffres sonen fou j'adore ce
truc je dis benah écoutez pas de
problème allez voir sur le site de l'INC
donc je donne le chiffre et
effectivement je je vais pas m'amuser
euh à inventer des chiffres quel est
l'intérêt il faut donner les chiffres
qui existent et heureusement ils
existent d'ailleurs ça c'est une grande
chance si vous voulez euh que j'ai en
tant qu'économiste aujourd'hui puisque
il y a quelques années j'aurais pas pu
faire ce que j'ai fais j'aurais pas pu
créer mon cabinet tout seul parce que il
y a quelqu quelques années les donc une
quinzaine quinzaine 15 20 ans les les
les statistiques coûtaient très cher il
fallait faire des abonnements qui
coûtent exement maintenant tout est
disponible sur Internet quasiment tout
donc il suffit de de chercher et
généralement on trouve donc chiffre très
simple la dette publique française
depuis 2020 elle a augmenté alors on n
pas encore les chiffres du 4e trimestre
2023 mais elle a augmenté de quasiment
750 milliards d'euros j'arrondis pour
faire simple 750 milliards d'euros
depuis janvier 2020 c'est quand même pas
rien sur la même période de combien a
augmenté le
PIB 350 milliards d'euros inflation
inclu c'estàdire que l'inflation a a
boosté un peu le payb artificiellement
donc on met trois de dette pour
récupérer un voilà c'està dire il manque
400 milliards pour faire simple par que
je dire c'est ça c'est ça le c'est ça le
drame c'estàdire que encore une fois cet
argent a été dépensé mais et le pire
c'est qu'on voit les services publics
qui se dégrade donc qu'est-ce qu'on est
en train de faire et je vais donner la
réponse la réponse elle est dans ce
qu'on appelle les dépenses de
fonctionnement ce qu'a dit Bruno l dit
je vais réduire les dépenses de
fonctionnement et là personne ne sait
parce que personne ne regarde j'en ai
parlé justement dans ma vidéo de Youtube
de cette semaine mais vous avez
également les chiffres sur l'INC sur le
chiffres de l'INC la les dépenses de
fonctionnement ont encore augmenté donc
en 2022 de 23 milliards d'euros en 2023
de 22 milliards d'euros vous rendez
compte juste le fonctionnement si bien
qu'aujourd'hui et là ça va faire mal les
dépenses de fonctionnement de la
puissance publique he tout le monde he
pas que l'État tout collectivité local
et cetera représente 35 % de la totalité
des dépenses publiques c'està dire comme
si vous avez une boîte et en fait votre
fonctionnement c'est 35 % de votre
activité on a quand même un problème
doncd que le le but de l'État il y a des
boîtes il y a des boîtes le
fonctionnement coûte très cher B oui
mais c'est ce qu'on a justement c'est
c'est c'est le problème c'est c'est
c'est les boîtes d'ailleurs qui sont le
plus menacé quand il y a des secous et
des grosses vagues c'est ce qu'on
appelle pour ceux qui ont fait des
théories économiques les coûts
organisationnel c'est ve dire qu'en gros
il arrive un moment où quand les boîtes
grossissent trop et ben ça coûte
tellement cher en terme d'organisation
que finalement ça s'effondre c'est ce
qu'on appelle dans les les mouvements de
fusion acquisition ce qu'on appelle les
synergies il y a des synergies donc 1 +
1 = 3 force formidable ça veut dire que
ça marche mais des fois 1 + 1 é= 2 ou 1
ou 0 donc c'est que ça marche pas c'est
exactement pareil donc on augmente ses
dépenses pour justement soi-disant je
dirais avoir la paix sociale mais ça ne
fonctionne pas et moi je suis pour un
État fort dans l'économie ça c'est la
force de la France la force de la France
c'est justement d'avoir un état moi je
suis pas ultra libéral je pense qu'il
faut effectivement du libéralisme mais
il faut également un état qui calme le
jeu qui évite justement les dérapages
notamment sociaux encore une fois moi je
les ai vécu c'est c'est c'est danger et
donc à partir de là c'est moi je pense
que le modèle social français à la base
il est très bon du libéralisme entre
guillemets plus effectivement de la
protection sociale ce qu'on appelle de
la redistribution quand ça marche sauf
que là quand je mets 750 milliards
d'euros de dette publique d'augmentation
hein aujourd'hui la dette publique c'est
quasiment 3100 milliards d'euros au
total et qu'en échange j'ai que 350
milliards d'euros de PIB donc il manque
400 milliards pour faire simple entre
guillemets je me dis il y a un problème
donc même si cet argent il a été dépensé
mais il a pas vous savez la dépense
publique c'est très simple c'est ce que
disait l'économiste Kens Kens c'est un
de mes économistes préféré d'ailleurs je
et AEK non AEC c'est différent c'est
plus dans les les courant monétariste
est venu après mais Ken si vous voulez
c'est lui qui a sauver le monde après le
crack de 29 hein c'està-dire que en gros
en gros pour faire simple à l'époque
donc c'était justement avant 29 c'était
l'ultralibéralisme mais le vrai
aujourd'hui ça existe plus
l'ultralibéralisme hein quand on dit que
la France c'est un pays ultralibéral par
exemple alors qu'on a 58 % de dépenses
publiqu par rapport au PIB 112 % de
dette publi bon c'est c'est ça n'a pas
de sens c'est c'est c'est c'est
complètement faux donc on n'est pas un
pays du tout ultraalibéral il y en a
plus aujourd'hui même même les
États-Unis c'est pas un pays
ultralibéral quand on voit sa dette
publique qui est en train d'exploser
donc on a l'Argentine est en train de se
recentrer l'Argentine mais bon en
attendant vous avez vu les dérapages qui
qui ont eu lieu donc en fait donc à ce
moment-là on a cette tout va bien mais
sauf que on a une CR de surproduction
c'est dire qu'il y a plus d'offre par
rapport à la demande l'inverse qu'on a
de l'inflation donc les prix baissent
donc là on a une ce qu'on appelle une
déflation en anglais ça'appelle une det
defflation ça veut dire on avait des
agents économiques hyper endettés et les
prix baissent donc ça veut dire ça
augmente le coût de la dette parce Queen
fait le coût de la dette c'est quoi
c'est le taux d'intérêt que vous payez
moins l'inflation SAF que comme
l'inflation elle est négatif moins et
moins ça fait plus donc ça augmente le
coût de la dette ça je suis pas trop
technique là ça ça vous me dites si et
ce que je dire pas c'est queà partir de
là par que une communauté qui est très
affutéequ pas voà c'est pour ça c'est
que c'est ce que vous m'avez dit donc je
je je me permets de d'avancer mais c'est
important parce que quand on explique
les choses tout le monde peut comprendre
ce que dire c'est des fois on me dit non
mais arrêtez non il faut expliquer les
choses le danger c'est que simplement
moi ça m'aré plusieurs fois on me dit
non non mais tu peux pas comprendre tu g
pas moi ça m'est arrivé les traders qui
me disaient vous savez des grands gens
très intelligents soit digigens qui me
disaient à l'époque des la crise des
subprime non marque tomber laisse tomber
tu peux pas comprendre en fait c'était
c'était une arnaque et ben on avait très
bien compris mais bon peu importe donc
je reviens sur cette crise de 20 9
effectivement donc on a cette defleion
donc cette cet excès d'ofre par rapport
à la demande et donc là ça s'effondre et
donc ça ça s'utoalimente parce comme on
était surendetté donc on a une faillite
généralisée cétait la fin du monde entre
guillemets de l'époque et là il y a donc
Kens qui arrive qui est un économiste
anglais qui va conseiller Roosevelt qui
dit écoute ton problème c'est la demande
tu as pas assez de demande donc il faut
que et ça c'est très important de
comprendre il dit il faut que l'État
avant l'état n'intervenait pas dans
l'économie c'est à partir de là qu'il
est arrivé dans l'économie il faut que
l'État fasse une relance budgétaire ve
dire il augmente ses dépenses publques
attention sur l'investissement pas
n'importe comment faire aussi bien sûr
un peu de social et l'investissement va
permettre de générer ce qu'on appelle un
effet multiplicateur et c'est ça la
bonne dépense publique c'est quand je
mets 100 de dépenses publiques mais ça
va me générer 200 de dépenses privées
genre des écoles des hôpitaux des routes
des des et de
l'innovationinovation central nucléire
exactement de des des avions et ce tout
ce qui a fait aussi la force de la
France he pendant un temps dans les
années 70 c'est parce qu'on a investi
justement dans l'innovation et ce qui a
fait ce qui fait encore notre force
aujourd'hui l'aérospatiale et cetera
donc à partir de là quand on a cette
dynamique de croissance donc ça qui est
très important donc Ken le problème
c'est que nous les français on s'est
arrêté là on a dit bon il faut faire de
la relance mais on n pas été plus loin
on a oublié la suite k qu'est-ce qu'il
dit ensuite dit voilà une fois que les
moteurs privés ont pris les relais des
moteurs publicque donc une fois que la
relance a marché donc on a plus besoin
de la relance on a plus besoin que
l'État injecte de de des liquidités
comme ça de façon démesurée donc il faut
que l'État revienne à un équilibre
budgétaire voir un excédent public ce
qui lui permettra de relancer la machine
lors de la prochaine crise parce qu'il y
en a toujours des crises ça revient
régulièrement c'est cyclique l'économie
donc si pour que ça marche il faut que
de temps en temps on ait des excédents
publics sauf que nous en France le
dernier excédent public qui remonte à
quand 94 non
1974 rendez compte dernière excédent ça
fait 50 ans fr le premier choc pétrolier
c'est ça céit ça avait déjà commencé
mais bon c'était encore les résultats de
des 30 glorieuses si vous voulez c'est
commencé à se terminé mais il y avait
encore très peu de chômage et cetera
mais ça fait 50 ans en France qu'on n
pas eu un excédent budgétaire rendez
compte et c'est ça la dette d'où elle
vient la dette parce que comment on est
passé de en 1980 on avait 20 % de dette
par rapport au PIB on est à 112 %
comment on en est arrivé là ben c'est
pas compliqué c'est que la dette c'est
le cumul des déficits publics en fait
les déficites s'accumulent c'est ça qui
fait la dette plus les intérêts de la
dette que j'ai évoqué tout à l'heure
donc qui évidemment démondre ça
n'arrange pas les choses et donc c'est
là où on est on a explosé et là on le on
a servi un peuple on lui fait la guerre
ou on lui met de la dette bah les deux
enfin avec les deux c'est possible mais
souvent malheureusement les deux vont de
pair c'est ça c'est ça qui est c'est ça
qui est dramatique mais encore une fois
le problème c'est que et ça ça date de
1980 en 1980 miteran avoir la boîte de
Pandore parce qu'à l'époque on avait pas
dette publici il a dit c'était la
fameuse relance demi-erran il a dit
allez on s'en fiche on va augmenter la
dette et depuis cette boîte de Pandor
par définition n'a pas été refermée et
on a continué donc cette fite en avant
elle continue et elle s'est aggravée
depuis la crise 2008 donc depuis 2007
elle s'est aggravée je vais vous donner
un chiffre très simple c'est ce fichier
fait très mal c'est un graphique que je
montre parfois sur dans mes vidéos c'est
ce qu'on adore ah ouis sur ta chaîne
c'est il y a du graphique il y a du
bâton il y a tout ce qui va bien ou
exactement ça c'est important mais non
parce qu' et alors et pour les abonnés
premium même ils peuvent avoir
effectivement les graphiques parce que
je je moi je veux diffuser effectivement
l'information donc très simple on a
depuis 2007 parce que 2007 c'était
soi-disant la rupture vous vous souvenez
on avait dit ça tout va changer bon
finalement rien a changé donc de 2007 à
2023 la dette publique française a
augmenté tenez-vous bien de 151 %. on n
pas le dernier le dernier chiffre de 4e
trimestre mais bon au 3e trimestre 2023
plus 151 % ok sur la même période le PIB
français a augmenté combien de combien
avec l'inflation 47 %. tu te rends
compte vous vous rendez compte c'est 3,2
fois plus c'est c'est inadmissible alors
vous alle dire tout le monde a fait
pareil non j'ai je peux j'ai le tableau
à disposition pour ce profite cas une
question internet comment faire
concurrence à des pays qui augmentent
leurs dettes encore plus rapidement et
ben voilà c'est ça qui est très étant
très intéressant parce que ce qui compte
ce qu'on appelle la soutenabilité de la
dette augmenter ma dette c'est pas grave
si et seulement si j'ai assez de
croissance pour payer les intérêts de la
dette voyez c'est ce qu'on appelle la
soutenabilité de la dette c'estire et ça
on peut tous le comprendre on est on est
un ménage on est une entreprise bah tout
le monde s'ente sinon si on s'endetttait
pas on pourrait pas acheter sa maison on
pourrait pas investir et cetera sinon on
sert beaucoup la ceinture voilà donc la
dette non la dette c'est très important
il faut de la dette mais à une condition
que cette dette génère suffisamment de
croissance d'activité au moins pour
rembourser les intérêts dettes or en
France depuis 2007 même si je prends 100
% d'impôt sur mon PIB sur ma hausse du
PIB je finance pas ma dette on a un
problème Houston on a un problème alors
justement si je reprends ce graphique là
cet écart 3ir sur Bruno et les conseils
lunettes Ros de l'économie ouais ouais
bien sûr mais c'est important parce que
la la base elle est là donc on a cette
explosion de la dette par rapport au PIB
donc c'est ça je prends le cas américain
par la dette publique a beaucoup plus
augmenté que chez nous mais comme le PIB
a beaucoup plus augmenté de chez nous
l'écart il est de 2,8 on est à 3,2
d'écart nous les Américains à
2,8 on fait pire que les Américains
c'està dire l'écart entre la dette et la
hausse du PIB on fait pire que les
Américains et alors les meilleurs élèves
évidemment sans avoir la plus grosse
armée du monde ah ouais en plus bien sûr
bon les Américains bon alors eux c'est
différent parce que ils ont le dollar
donc tant qu'ils ont le dollar he c'est
la phrase de John Connelly en 60
le dollar c'est notre devise et votre
problème vous connaissez donc c'est
c'est c'est tout le problème nous on a
pas ça on on a essayé en créant l'euro
mais ça pas marché il faut être honnête
on n pas réussi à concurrencer le dollar
donc si je reprends cet écart de dette
si je prends le cas allemand et bien
l'Allemagne a augmenté sa dette de 62 %
depuis 2007 c'est beaucoup mais son PIB
a augmenté de 67 %. voilà ça c'est ça
c'est du sérieux c'estd que globalement
si j'augmente ma dette mais mon PIB
augmente au moins au aussi vite voire
plus vite alors là il y a pas de
problème là ça quel chef d'entreprise
comprend ça ben tous les chefs
d'entreprises comprennent ça est-ce que
la France fait de la cavalerie est-ce
qu'est-ce que c'est la cavalerie bah je
dirais je dirais de la fuite en avant
parce que la cavalerie ça veut dire
c'est c'est du madof quoi la cavalerie
quoi c'està dire bien enfin c'est vrai
que quand on regarde le système des
retraites c'est du Ponzi ouais mais
c'est c'est pareil c'est plus ou moins
la même chose c'estàdire que globalement
vous vous payez avec ceux que qui
viennent vous donner de l'argent quoi
donc vous payez les anciens avec les
nouveaux mais c'est l'histoire qu'on
raconte souvent sur sur sur la la le
système de retraite par répartition bon
on pose la question à madof le juge lui
pose la question Mons madof comment vous
avez eu cette idée de de faire payer les
les les anciens par par les nouveaux dit
ben c'est pas compliqué j'ai regardé le
système de retraite par répartition en
France j'ai fait pareil parce qu'en fait
c'est exactement ce qui se passe en
France c'estàdire que nous c'est un
scandale d'État hein mais évidemment
évidemment non non attention la retraite
par répartition c'est important c'est
c'est un acquis sociale mais elle marche
plus aujourd'hui c'est dans les annes
plus d'enfants mais c'est c'est le
problème il est beaucoup plus grave
estce que nos enfants gagnent encore
moins que nous il y a ça aussi mais un
chiffre très simple dans les années
chiffres de l'INC aussi de la DARES bon
de tout le monde ouais bah oui hein de
on a en en dans les années 70 encore
voir début 80 il y a 3,4 actifs pour un
retraité c'est pas de problème ça marche
parce que je rappelle la retraite parti
répartition le principe c'est que quand
vous et moi on cotise pour notre
retraite en fait c'est pas pour notre
retraite qu'on cotise on cotise pour
payer les actuels retraités en espérant
que quand nous on sera à la retraite il
y aura assez d'actifs pour payer notre
retraite ouais on peut prier peut-être
il faut garder l'espoir il faut avir la
foi faut garder la foi ce que tu par là
c'est que aujourd'hui il y en a combien
il y a 1,4 actifs pour un retraité donc
il faut pas de grand mathématicien pour
comprendre qu'on a un problème alors
évidemment les caisses de retraite elles
vivent sur leur pactol accumulé pendant
des des décennies donc ça passe encore
mais vous avez vu ce qui s'est passé
l'année dernière qui a été évité de
justesse on voulait prendre l'argent de
l'agir Carco pour financer les retraites
des fonctionnaires donc agir Carco privé
privée qui a géré son pognon comme un
bon père de famille on on a reçu le le
président directeur général de l'agir
Carco ici et on voulait mettre la main
dessus c'est ça à hauteur de combien 2
milliards il voulait per on sait pas
parce que globalement je pense qu'il
voulait fusionner en fait c'était énorme
c'est dire on voulait dire bon
finalement bah c'est la même caisse donc
on met on met tout donc c'était assez
énorme ça ressemblit un peu à l'URSS
quand même non ben heureusement on l'a
pas fait heureusement on l'a pas fait
parce que là ça aurait pas je pense ça
aurait pas passé le gouvernement aurait
été aurait peut-être été aurait capoté
certainement bon finalement il a changé
depuis mais par là c'est que le 493
aurait été validé enfin non non validé
donc la moau de censure aurait été
validée je pense c'est ce qui a fait que
ça a été évité de justesse finalement
mais vous savez ça c'est une bonne
question c'est parce que si on revient
sur la dette publique parce que tout à
l'heure j'ai 3100 milliards d'euros mais
ça c'est la dette publique officielle et
la dette privé mais si je prends ce
qu'on appelle le hors bilan oh non c'est
ben si c'estàd notamment notamment le
paiement des retraites des
fonctionnaires là je double la mise j'ai
plus de 6000 milliards d'euros de dett
publique alors quand on me dit les
Français ont de l'épargne il y a 6000
milliards de d'épargne des Français et
même 7000 milliards ouais 7000 soyons
grand prince sans côter le l'immobilier
hein cette ouais mais ça c'est un
scandale d'État ça aussi moi moi ça me
fait flipper çace que l'expression moi
si vous voulez ça je l'ai je l'ai vécu
dans parce que parfois ça m'arrive de
faire des aussi des d'aller dans là à
l'Assemblée au Sénat dans les
commissions et cetera et c'est arrivé ça
m'est arrivé il y a au moins une
quinzaine d'années donc c'est pas
nouveau on m'a donné exactement cet
argument là imaginez on a 7000 milliards
d'épépoque un peu moins on prend 10 %
quel est le problème et on rembourse
facilement une partie de notre dette
donc ça c'est dans les tuyaux j'espère
que ça n'arrivera jamais mais évidemment
la tentation est énorme mais ça c'est
pas un argument on n pas le droit de
faire ça sachant que nous avons déjà une
spoliation organisée qui est l'impôt
n'oublions pas qu'aujourd'hui nous
sommes numéro 1 du monde en terme de
pression fiscale ce qu'on appelle le
poids des prélèvements obligatoires par
rapport au payb donc là on a deux
sources je cite mes sources Inc 45,4 %
du PIB donc de prélèvement obligatoire
de cotisation cotisation c'està dire non
les impôts et les taxes au sens large et
donc tous les prélèvements également
cotisation et selon Eurostat qui
harmonise on est à 47 % du PIB bon
numéro 1 du monde également alors des
fois le marque passe devant nous mais là
bon on est quand même devant numéro 1 du
monde vous rendez compte ce donc on peut
pas dire qu'en France on paye pas
d'impôt alors quand on me dit oui on a
baissé les impôts ça ça ça me fait
marrer ça aussi excusez-moi l'expression
alors on me dit dernièrement ça m'est
arrivé cette semaine sur LCI quelqu'un
me dit non mais en fait votre ça veut
rien dire ce chiffre comment ça ça veut
rien dire ben bien sûr que ça veut dire
quelque chose c'est l'état justement de
de l'imposition en France c'està dire
alors bien sûr une partie normalement
parce qu'il y a des cotisations
également on va les récupérer on espère
pour nos retraites mais c'est pas sûr
mais en tout cas aujourd'hui on a cette
ponction qui est là en espérant qu'on va
récupérer une partie mais c'est pas sûr
donc ce par là c'est que cette ponction
elle existe elle est là donc c'est là
qui est le problème aujourd'hui quand
Bruno Lemer dit je pourrais pas
augmenter les impôts je vais pas
augmenter les impôts ben évidemment il
peut pas les augmenter on est on est
déjà numéro 1 du monde je te coupe vas-y
alors c'est parce que où va le pognon
c'est parce que c'est mal employé c'est
parce que on a fait de la subordation de
vote depuis des années du genre je te
garantis un petit emploi genre de
fonctionnaire de de technicien de
surface ou quoi que ce soit ça vient de
quoi ça vient ça vient parce que on a
des gestionnaires c'est des des Monch à
Balis alors déjà il faut pas oublier que
on a ce qu'on appelle comme dans
beaucoup de pays riches et beaucoup pays
dans le monde d'ailleurs un
vieillissement de la population donc les
dépenses maladie par définition
augmentent et comme une grande partie de
ces dépenses sont financées par l'État
donc inévitablement elles augmentent ça
c'est sûr ça représente combien ça donc
c'està-dire la charge des retraité des
vieux alors non alors bon non par
rapport à l'ensemble des dépenses
publiques faut pas pas exagérer non
c'est quoi c'est c'est 5 5
% bon c'est pas rien mais mais ce que je
dire c'est que ça a augmenté ça a quand
même augmenté hein les quand tu prends
toutes les dépenses médicales par
exemple en France donc y compris dans le
privé donc qu'on paye nous-même c'est 11
% tu VO mais tu après la moitié c'est
pour ça que il y a il y a le ministre
qui dit bon c'est les Fran ils vont trop
aux urgences ou ils sont trop malades ou
non mais c'est mais c'est une réalité
c'est je fais l'avocat du diable non non
mais c'est c'est normal c'està dire que
on a un pays qui vieillit donc
mécaniquement voilà et on a et on a même
un PS excusez-moi je je dis un peu
souvent d'hypocondriaque hein donc sans
être méchant hein bon mais moi je dis
souvent moi on voit les médecins mais on
se porte alors fois on a pas le choix
bien entendu he mais je veux dire mais
c'est que faut faire GAE parce qu'aux
États-Unis il voit pas les médecins ils
ont tous de l'UR PCE ils ont des Chicou
pourris ils je dis pas qu' par qu'X
ÉtatsUnis là c'est l'inverse c'est pour
ça je dis le modèle américain n'est pas
le bon parce qu'aux États-Unis là on
paye le vrai le vrai prix à chaque fois
le juste prix mais ça coûte une fortune
donc là on y'y vont pas donc nous nous
nous c'est l'inverse on sait même pas
combien ça coûte et moi j'avais donné un
conseil il y a quelques années par
exemple à nos dirigeants je leur a dit
par exemple quelqu'un qui va voir un
même médecin pour la même pathologie
peut aller voir 10 fois 10 médecins
différents il va être remboursé à chaque
fois alors que dans beaucoup de pays
dans le monde aujourd'hui on dit voilà
ok tu peux aller voir 10 médecins la
première fois tu payes pas c'est
remboursé par l'État puis après c'est
c'est c'est toi qui décide de pas croire
ton premier médecin donc c'est c'est toi
qui finance al après on peut changer de
médecin référent et cetera quand même
mais voà ça c'est un truc simple donc
c'est évident il y a bien sûr tout ce
qui est fraude sociale fraude fiscale et
qu' faut qu' faut aussi regard
évidemment il faut encore une fois
fiscale ça représente combien tout n'est
pas tout n'est pas encore une fois alors
les chiffres varient c'està-dire que on
est alors on est autour des 20 milliards
des fois certains disent 50 milliards
bon c'est compliqué parce que par dé
l'vasion fiscale ça représente combien
l'évasion fiscale ça représente combien
encore une fois l'évasion fiscale c'est
pas de la fraude non c'est de
l'optimisation c'est quoi c'est allégal
non mais le problème c'est que c'est
antipatriotique non non c'est c'est
enfin encore une fois le problème c'est
que c'est ça c'est ça qui qui est
subtile en France vous savez qu' on a
l'une des notamment on est numéro 1 du
monde des impôts mais on a l'impôt le
plus complexe c'estd on a un code des
impô sa si j'étais président de la
République je su alors d'c je je je
m'encombreraai pas de ce gen par que je
dis au téléspectateurs qu' on sutoyait
déjà avant donc on peut moi ça me
dérange pas je je préfère suoyer de
petite subtilité l'évasion fiscale c'est
antipatriotique donc va falloir qu'on
s'explique non non moi je suis d'accord
avec toi sur l'Impôt sur l'impôt sur les
sociétés quand on voit Macron baisser
l'impôt sur les sociétés c'est parce que
il fait ça pour récupérer des miettes
parce qu'ils savent pertinemment que les
les les les chefs d'entreprise savent
comment contourner l'impôt non mais
c'est c'est pire que ça c'està dire
qu'en fait comme les dirigeants français
ils sont parce qu'ils sont t'appelle les
dirigeants françaisah dirigeants les
haut fonctionnair et cetera qui dirige
le pays he c'est pas bon bien sûr il y a
le ministre et cetera mais c'est quand
même les haut fonctionnaires qui
dirigent le pays de il faut re honnête
donc quand ils savent bien qu'il y a
trop d'impôts en France donc quand ils
créent un impôt qu'est-ce qu'ils font à
côté quelques années plus tard ils
créent la niche fiscale qui va avec pour
dire écoutez bon et donc c'est là où
l'impôt français il qui trouvent pas la
niche son voir et ben évidemment l'impôt
français est très inégalitaire parce que
ceux qui ont les moyens de se payer un
fiscaliste ça coûte cher quand même
fiscaliste ah ben eux ils échappent mais
c'est pas de la fraude c'est parce que
l'État a créé le c'est l'État qui a créé
ça tu comprends c'est c'est pas encore
une fois une fraude c'est l'État qui dit
bon ok là j'ai peut-être été un peu loin
sur la fraude fiscale sur la il plus
révélateur sur sur le niveau fiscal donc
on va on va effectivement créer un petit
subterfuge donc donc c'est c'est un
pousce au crime tu comprends hein et
d'ailleurs même Kens disait le le but de
de de l'homoconomicus entre guillemets
c'est justement de baisser au maximum
son son imposition parce que nous en
France comme j'voqué tout à l'heure on
est imposé en permanence qu' soit imposé
sur le revenu c'est très bien mais on a
l'imposition comme tu sais sur la TVA on
a l'imposition surtout c'està dire sur
les dividends bien entendu doncimp sur
les sociétésimp sur les sociéés et ainsi
de suite sur ça non mais c'est dire que
en fait le problème c'est que la société
qui moi je pense qu'il c'est bien de
payer des impôts c'est important de
payer des impôts il faut être fier il
faut exactement il faut être fier de
payer des impôts le problème c'est quand
on paye plusieurs fois ê fier de la
France aussi quand on paye des impôts
mais encore une fois moi je voyage
beaucoup dans le monde comme toi
j'imagine comme beaucoup de monde qui
nous écoute VO ah tu arrêté ok tu as
bien fait mais enfin c'est bien mais
mais quand on vient en France on se rend
compte de la chance qu'on a de de vivre
en France ne serce que par nos aide par
contre il y a d'autres aspects que on
est ça commence à à déraper donc là là
on se dit attention ça va pas durer
parce qu'en fait qu'est-ce qui se passe
on tire sur la corde donc là la corde
elle tient sur un fil donc tant que le
fil ne casse pas on me dit tu vois la
corde elle tient ou mais quand le fil va
casser alors là là ça va être très j'
reviens j'en reviens à notre ami Bruno
oui Bruno le meilleur ministre des
Finances il fait quoi il fait de la
communication desm control c'està-dire
la communication de crise il est attends
recommence pas à repartir d'un coup
laisse-moi la parole une-y je te oui moi
je suis bavard c'est ça non tu es pas
bavard tu es efficace ah c'est gentil
c'est gentil non je suis pas gentil je
fait deux fois que je te le dis commence
d'accord d'accord ok et donc le Bruno le
mer il fait quoi il fait de la
communication pour éviter de paniquer il
fait de la communication pour rassurer
les investisseurs étrangers Bruno Bruno
Le Maire il gère un océan avec une
petite cuillère Bruno le mer j'aime bien
cette expression il fait des petites
apparition il dit vous inquiétez pas
tout se passe bien pour ensuite refaire
un journal de TF1 à 20h en disant bon
les gars on s'est planté c'est pas 1,4
c'est c'est 1 % qu'est-ce qui fait Bruno
Leem alors il s'est passé un truc énorme
quandême cette semaine je pense parce
que on sen on s'est pas rendu compte
quand même parce que c'est l'audition de
Jean-Marc
janovici non non non non je parle de par
rapport à Bruno le mer tu P sur Bruno le
mer je te répon sur Bruno le mer le
20EUR de Bruno le ma c'était
exceptionnel parce qu'en fait moi je
l'ai vécu il y encore quelques temps bon
je pas on n pas le droit on va pas
dénigrer moi moi je justement il faut
pas déig moi je trouve que c'est
quelqu'un à la base moi il m'a reçu dès
2017 et
et il m'a donné l'impression de quelun
qui voulait faire quelque chose et je
pense un politique ça c'est normal je
fais avoir voilà non mais d'accord mais
ce que je dis pas là c'est que le le le
problème c'est que justement il faut pas
être politique il faut aujourd'hui ça
c'est c'est trop grave ce qui est en
train de se passer et donc moi grave
pourquoi je te recoupe c'estve alors je
vais te donner je vais te répondre
qu'est-ce qui moi ça m'a surpris en fait
que il annonce là parce que depuis des
mois on sait très bien que la croissance
moi ça fait des mois que j'annonce je
suis pas de de 20 hein j'annonce 0,5 %
de croissance pour 2024 Laé des traces
le F bien sûr le FMI 0,9 % l'OCDE 0,6 %
il y a que les économistes de salon qui
sirent les pompes notamment français on
pas donné de nom qui eux évidemment ils
disent non vous avez raison monsieur le
Maire bref mais ça fait déjà des mois
qu'on voit que ça ça ça tient pas la
route qu'est-ce qui s'est passé là moi
j'étais surpris je m'attendais pas là ce
dimanche pour qu'il nous disent ben non
finalement désolé c'est pas 1 4 ça va
être 1 en fait il a devancé les agences
de notation non je pense que à mon avis
on l'a averti parce que les agences de
notation ça fait déjà longtemps qu'elles
auraient dû dégrader la note de la
France mais je suis désolé de le dire
elles ne font pas leur boulot ou elles
le font peut-être trop bien non non
elles ne le font pas du tout c'est
peut-être parce que les Chinois ont créé
leurs propres agences de notation non
non non non non c'est tu veux le
problème c'est que il y a un problème de
base c'est que les agents de notation
sont payés par les gens qu'ell notent
faut être honnête donc il y a un
problème de base donc moi je me rappelle
très bien parce que j'ai vécu la crise
des ils essayent de faire leur boulot qu
quand même ouais non bien sûr bien sûr
je faut pas jeter le bébé avec l'au
dubain bien entendu faut pas dénigrer
mais ce que par là c'est que moi je me
rappelle de 2007 2006 2007 la crise des
subprime je l'ai vécu de l'intérieur
hein j'étais encore chez TEX à l'époque
et il y avait un truc qui qui qui me
gênit là aussi si tu veux ça c'est une
une règle base de l'économie qui est
très importante qui qui est qui est de
dire que plus le rendement augmente plus
le risque augmented que si tu veux un
rendement élevé si tu veux gagner de
l'argent il faut prendre des risques si
tu veux pas prendre de risque tu auras
un rendement faible tu vois le problème
c'est que l'être humain est ainsi fait
qui veut constamment changer cette règle
moi ça m'arrive tous les jours on me dit
vous avez pas un truc là j'ai un peu
d'épargne voilà moi je veux investir euh
mais euh gagner de l'argent mais sans
risque ben non ça n'existe pas et donc
la crise des subprimes c'est exactement
ça c'estàd qu'on a pris des dettes
subprime extrêmement dangereuses on les
a titrisé c'est ve dire on les a
transformé en des titres comme des
obligations et ces titres étaient notés
triple A par les agence de notation la
veille encore et oui c'est-àdire que
Triple A c'était la vertu de triple on
savait pas ce que c'était quoi c'était
lendouillette d'ailleurs c'est 5A
l'endouillette he pour les connaisseurs
boss les beau boss tu m des enouillettes
toi non mais bon mais je connais et donc
et donc ce pas là c'est que les les
lesations quelques semaines avant
c'était encore triple A et moi bon je
peux le dire il il y a prescription j'ai
posé la question après je dis mais vous
avez pas vu vous êtes pas rendu compte
qu'il y avait un problème ils on dit
écoutez on avait des notices
d'explication des des produits avec
c'était des dictionnaires avec des
formules mathématiques dans tous les
sens donc on a on a fait confiance quoi
tu te rends compte le truc et donc c'est
exactement ce pareil que les enux de
notation elles vont pas dégrader elles
vont dégrader la note de la France comme
la Grèce quand ça sera la catastrophe et
donc là c'est la catastrophe donc moi je
pense que et le problème de ça c'est
quoi c'est que comme on a pas eu de
sanction ben on a continué ce qu'on
appelle en théorie des jeux un alléa
moral ça veut dire qu'en fait tu as pas
de sanction je continue c'est la blague
de Coluche hein tant que je tant que je
gagne je joue c'est blague hein bon pour
les plus anciens donc c'est exactement
ça moi pendant des années j'ai été voir
tout à l'heure je l'évoqué tous nos
dirigeants je le dit écoutez les gars en
jeais pas les gars par chois messieurs
s'il vous plaît messieurs dames arrêtez
d'augmenter la dette publique il me
disait parce que sinon les taux
d'intérêt vont augmenter donc ça va être
dangereux ça va casser la croissance ah
ok donc il faisaient quand même un petit
peu attention mais là depuis quelques
années qu'est-ce depuis la planche habé
depuis 2015 la planche habé a commencé
en 2015 en dans la zone euro et bien
qu'est-ce qu'ils me disent mais Marc
arrêtez de nous embêter avec votre truc
là vot regardez plus la dette publique
augmente plus les taux d'intérêt baisse
allz à moral donc il av il y avait
aucune sanction et le le le sommet
c'était pendant le la crise du
coronavirus où là on avait même des taux
d'intérêt négatifs il faut faut se
rendre compte quand même que pour avoir
le droit de prêter à l'état français il
fallait payer les taux d'intérêt négatif
et moi je je titill des fonds
d'investissement comme ça que je
conseille un petit peu de temps en temps
y compris américain je leur disais
comprenez attendez les gars je comprends
pas là vous achetez des des des
obligations d'État français tonég vous
êtes sûr de perdre vous savez ce qui me
répondait oui mais au moins on sait
combien on va perdre bah oui c'est dire
en gros c'était important on sait qu'on
va perdre 01 c'est mieux de perdre 01
que de perdre - 10 parce qu'il y avait
un tel cataclysme sécurisit leur
investissement ouais mais on marche sur
la tête et d'ailleurs c'est pourquoi on
achète encore la dette publique
française parce que au royaume au
royaume des borgnes les aveugles sont
rois inverse au royaume des aveugles les
borgnes son roi il est tard il est
tard je vais boir un petit peu tiens tu
me redonnes la parole
merci euh revenons pardon tu tu tu tu
m'as déconcentré là non non mais bon
revenons à Bruno Le Maire et revenons tu
tu vraiment tu fait non mais non on
m'appelle le P de boule donc le le donc
qu'est-ce il mal consé il a pas il a pas
de moelle épinière il y a pas de courage
politique auudessus de lui je vais pas
aller jusque là mais par rapport
justement à ça moi je pense que ce qui
s'est passé cette semaine enfin depuis
quelques semaines il y avait eu la même
chose en 2012 2013 avec François hand
hand les agences de notation ont été le
voir il ont dit Monsieur Hollande on va
vous dégrader méchamment et à l'époque
là Hollande qui avait qui était Luu sur
un programme d'augmentation des
dépensesques et cetera mon ennemi c'est
la finance et et c'est ça et c'est là où
il a nommé Macron si tu te souviens et
parce qu'il a flippé il a dit ou là là
c'est dangereux et cetera et moi je sais
qu'à l'époque bon on va pas donner de
nom non plus mais certains médias
m'avait blacklisté en disant non tu
arrêtes de dire ça que la dette publique
augmente c'est pas bien qu'on va
dégrader voilà et comme aujourd'hui je
dis là je prends des risques he c'est
très intéressant pourquoi tu prends des
risques c'est très intéressant parler
moi moi maintenant j'ai j'ai rien à
avant bon j'ai rien à perdre qu'est-ce
qu'il vont me faire moi j'ai mon j'ai
mon cabinet donc il va rien me faire
c'est c'est très intéressant ce que tu
dis c'est-à-dire que il y avait une
autocensure médiatique pour les gars qui
essayaient de dire attention il faut
quand même avoir un autre prisme de
lecture parce que on est exposé à ça ça
ça mais elle elle est permanente mais
elle est là encore aujourd'hui et on t'a
blacklisté ouais de certains certaines
émissions bien sûr moi mais tu as eu
confirmation ou c'est un bruit de couir
moi je pas donné ma ma ma ma d'accord
pasme é
dansetteissionur
don lui quia dit jamais j'aurais imaginé
un truc pareil c'est lui qui m'a dit on
avait une liste de l'Élysée avec des
gens à ne plus inviter tu étais dessus
quelle année rappelle-moi l'année
c'était en 2013 donc encore sous fr S
françisand et donc bref mais aujourd'hui
c'est pas et donc il s'est passé donc
c'est que je voulais dire il s'est passé
un changement très important cette
semaine parce que il y a encore quelques
temps donc on dis bah la dette publique
on s'en fiche complètement et même même
Bruno Le Maire et sauf que là il nous a
dit écoutez les gars on peut plus donc
moi je pense que comme s François
Hollande de notation alors j'ai pas de
preuve mais c'est mon non si c'est un
bruit de couloir je veux pas l'entendre
c'est pas un bruit de couloir ce que je
dire c'est que c'est c'est mon c'est mon
analyse aujourd'hui la note de la France
doit être dégradée donc les agences de
notation on quand même une crédibilité à
tenir tu sais ce que ça ça implique si
si la note de la France est dégradée ça
implique quoi la charge de la dette elle
elle va augmenter t d'intérêt vont
augmenter mais c'est norm et donc ça va
être double effet qui se coule ah ben
évidemment mais encore une fois on est
mais je veux dire on est pourquoi elles
sont là pour noter on est là pour don
pour dire pourquoi on va dégrader des
pays qui ont des qui ont fait je don
l'exemple de l'Italie par exemple triple
B l'Italie donc note beaucoup moins
importante que nous on est encore double
a plus a moin donc on est quand même
bien tu vois donc triple B l'Italie
alors que l'Italie a fait plus d'efforts
de que nous en terme de réduction de sa
dette la Grèce pareil donc tu vois il y
a deux POS de mesur donc si on on est au
hnê encore une fois les enjeux de
notation doivent dégrader l' de la
France donc c'est inévitable et donc moi
c'est ce qui pour moi c'est mon analyse
donc là comme par hasard on dit voilà ça
y est on révise la prévision de
croissance en France il faut faire des
des efforts et donc c'est ce que tu dis
tout à l'heure le danger moi ce qui m'a
crainte c'est qu'on fasse surtout du
marketing pour justement faire plaisir
aux agences de notation entre guillemets
hein mais ça j'aime pas ça parce que
souvent on me dit ah on fait tout ça
pour faire plaisir à l'Europe pour faire
plaisir à Bruxelles faire non s'il faut
baisser la dette publique si' fout
arrêter les déficites publics c'est pas
pour Bruxelles c'est pour nos enfants tu
comprends parce que et même pour nous
parce que ça aussi quand on me dit oui
mais c'est nos enfants qui vont payer
donc déjà c'est pas sympa pour eux mais
c'est nous qui payons tout à l'URE je l'
évoqué la charte d'intérêt de la dette
c'est pas nos enfants qui la paye c'est
nous et quand Bruno il nous demande non
il nous demande pas il dit je vais faire
la chasse pour trouver 10 milliards dans
notre fonctionnement ouais mais ça c'est
cosmétique si tu veux c'est pas
compliqué les dépenses de fonctionnement
tout à l'heure je l'ai évooqué hein de
toute la puissance publique ont augmenté
de 23 milliards d'euros en 2022 et à peu
près 22 milliards on n pas encore le
chiffre du 4e trimestre ça sera autour
des 21 22 milliards en 2024 en 2023 ça
sera pare en 2024 donc quand on dit on
va réduire de 5 milliards 10 non 10 au
total mais il a dit 5 milliards sur les
dépenses de fonctionnement d'accord donc
déjà ça va être comp donc c'est c'est
c'est c'est rien il y a qu'à lire le
rapport de la Cour des comptes chaque
année moi c'est ça c'est je je j'invite
ceux qui ont s y a des insomnies par
exemple exemple tu sais pas quoi faire
le soir tu regardes le rapport de la
Cour des comptes alors j'écoute Marc
Toti voilà ça ça c'est encore mieux hein
mais je veux dire mais mais c'est vrai
que quand on voit sa cour de la ça fait
des années que ça dure j'adorais
Philippe segin exactement mais le
rapport de la Cour des comptes il le
dernier là il y a au moins le jour j'ai
calculé un peu près grosso modo il y
avait 22 milliards d'euros d'économie à
faire c'estàd juste tu arrêtes le
gaspillage par que c'est ça en fait la
cour des compes de dit là vous avez
déconné là là il y a un ce qu'on appelle
le milfeu administratif c'estàd que tu
as des couches partout tu fais n'importe
quoi comme dépenses qui servent à rien
ça ok tu vois
donc c'est incroyable et d'ailleurs le
rapport de la Cour des comptes ça on le
dit pas assez hein il donne depuis des
années il dit que ce qu'on appelle
l'actif net de l'État est négatif c'est
dire que même si je vends tous les actif
de l'État je rembourse pas la dette donc
ça pour une entreprise qu'on appelle la
faillite c'est pour ça que François
Fillon il disait je suis à la tête d'un
État qui est en faillite bien sûr mais
ce ce qui est fou c'est que il l'a dit
mais malheureusement on l'a pas laissé
faire c'est on l'a pas laissé que ça
soit d'abord Sarkozi parce que Sarkozi
lu dès qu'il a dit ça il lui a tapé sur
les doigs dit calme-toi et après bon bah
comme on le sait il a pas été élu
président et ça a été Macron qui l'a qui
a été élu parce que justement voilà
c'est c'est vrai que aujourd'hui il y a
toute ce que j'appelle bon je pasêre
complotiste encore une fois mais il y a
quand même une tout ce qui est
l'establichement et cetera qui veut pas
que ça bouge qui veut pas que ça bouge
trop on avait une grande discussion avec
un vieux monsieur d'ailleurs qui était
décédé qui était très gentil d'ailleurs
il s'appelait Henri Armand ça te parle
ou oui on avait une grande discussion à
propos de Macron avant même qu'il soit
président de la République question
internet que dire des États-Unis qui
sont encore classés triple A par mood et
AA plus par
tn ils ont perdu ils on ils ont perdu
ils ont perdu un un a c'est pareil la
différence que j'ai voé tout à l'heure
c'estàd qu'en fait les États-Unis c'est
un cas à part parce qu'ils ont le dollar
donc faut comprendre qu'aujourd'hui euh
on a quasiment 80 % des des non 70 %
livre exact du de la Banque Mondial faut
être précis ça ça dépend des années mais
donc des des des réserves de change dans
le monde qui sont en
dollar l'euro c'est autour des 20 % quoi
un peu moins donc tu as 50 % du commerce
mondial qui est en dollar alors que le
commerce américain c'est que 11 % du
commerce mondial ce qui veut dire que
les 2/ers du commerce en dollar ne sont
pas américains donc ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire que tu as une demande mondiale
de dollars c'est ça ce qu'il faut bien
comprendre c'est ça le le piège pour
nous entre guillemets c'est que quand
les Américains font la planche habillée
quand ils font la dette publique qui
c'est qui paye c'est nous c'est le reste
du monde les Africains ouais non tout le
monde le reste du monde c'està dire que
globalement et encore une c'est la
phrase de John Connelly en 71 avant
avant 71 souvenir que le dollar était
convertible en or c'estàdire qu'on
devait avoir autant d'or à la Réserve
fédérale américaine que de dollars et en
71 comme après il y avait la guerre du
Vietnam et cetera il y avait plus assez
d'or donc les Américains ont dit on
arrête ils ont pris un risque énorme
c'estàd que on aurait là à ce momentl
ils aurait pu être ruiner les Américains
mais comme on avait énormément de
dollars dans nos réserves de change les
Américains ont pris un risque calculé on
dit si vous voulez pas si vous acceptez
pas le deal nous sommes runés mais vous
aussi parce que tous vos dollars il
valent plus rien et ils font pareil avec
les Chinois aujourd'hui il y a pour ça
attends on on va switcher géopolitique
vas-y continue sur ch chinois
aujourd'hui 3200 milliards de dollars de
réserve de change ils se dédollaris ils
se dédollarisent un petit peu hein ouais
mais quand même ils ont 1000 milliards
de dollars de bon du Trésor américain la
dette américaine c'est combien de
trilliards 33000 milliards donc 33
trilliards donc si tu veux même 34 mais
on est même à 34 parce que tu sais que
il y a le le ça j'is le la cloque là tu
sais le comment s'appelle le l'horloge
l'horloge américaine on peut aller sur
internet c'est super bien fait on voit
le les chiffres qui défilent en à la
seconde quoi tu vois voir la dette
publique américaine bon mais comme j'ai
tout à l'heure la force des Américains
c'est que un cette dette elle fait quand
même de la croissance et là tu le vois
au niveau de de de l'innovation des g
fames et de l'intelligence artificielle
gaz de schiste du gaz de schiste
évidemment bien sûr ils ont c'estàd gaz
de roche mer oui mais ils font de la
croissance et tu as beau tourner
retourner ils ont un taux de chômage
même si on dit ou ils font de la
croissance au détribment de qui non
c'est moi je c je suis pas sur ce ce
comment dire cette croissance c'est pas
forcément au détriment quand tu fais de
l'innovation c'est pas au détriment
c'est tu cré quelque chose de N nouveau
tu comprends ça c'est justement c'est la
version maltusienne je sais que ça c'est
notre débat mais sur la décroissance on
me dit voilà ben en fait le le arrêtez
votre croissance parce que la terre est
ronde ok donc on vit dans un monde fini
donc la croissance infinie dans un monde
fini techniquement c'est pas possible ce
qui est complètement vrai sauf que si
vous faites la décroissance qu'est-ce
qui se passe c'est veut dire une baisse
du niveau de PIB baisse du niveau de vie
donc comment on fait pour même avant ça
comment on fait pour payer la retraite
des fonctionnaires par exemple mais je
te donne un exemple ça c'est pour nous
les pays riches entre guillemets mais
les pays pauvres ça je donne un chiffre
que que je donne que j'ai déjà donné
plusieurs fois mais que notamment dans
dans mes livres mais qui qui est
incroyable que personne ne ne ne peu de
monde cite mais qui pourtant vient de la
Banque mondiale donc c'est tout à fait
c'est tout à fait officiel c'estàdire
que dans les années 80 au début des
années 80 tiens-toi bien il y avait 50 %
de l'humanité qui vivait sous le seuil
de pauvreté extrême je challenge après
hein c'est dire avec moins de 1 dollar
par jour d'accord
50 % de l'humanité aujourd'hui on a
combien de personnes de l'humanité qui
vivent sous le seuil de pauvreté
extrêmeoup 8,5 %. tu comprends donc
c'est c'est c'est c'est un progrès
humanitaire énorme ça c'est dû à quoi
mais c'est dû à la croissance c'est duu
à la mondialisation et c'est viable à
long terme alors voilà le problème c'est
ça finit par s'arrêter et d'ailleurs le
problème c'est qu'aujourd'hui 90 % de
ces 8,5 % malheureusement sont en
Afrique parce que l'Afrique c'est le
c'est le continent où devrait avoir le
plus de croissance c'est là où il y enn
eu le moins malheureusement donc c'est
ce qui fait que ça bloque et donc l'Asie
par contre bon évidemment elle c'est
elle qui a le plus c'est plus le plus
réveillé entre guillemets donc si tu
fais de la décroissance qu'est-ce que ça
ça revient à quoi ça revient à dire bon
bah nous les pays riches ça fait des
années qu'on qu'on fait de la croissance
sans compter et maintenant que vous les
pays pauvres entre guillemets vous nous
rattrapez vous nvez plus le droit de
faire de la croissance ça peut pas
marcher tu comprends donc c'est ce qui
fait que d'ailleurs pourquoi les la COP
21 22 23 26 je plusù on est aujourd'hui
c'est c'est c'est du pipo ça marchera
jamais donc et même pour nous pays
riches comme tu l'as bien dit si demain
il y a de la décroissance comment donc
ça veut dire du chômage ça veut dire de
la crise sociale la crise sociétal
comment tu payes les retraites bon donc
ça marche pas mais tu as ce problème
croissance infinie dans un monde fini
comment tu fais ben il faut créer
d'autres sources de croissance ça veut
dire notamment en terme d'innovation
mais c'est pas que la high-tech c'est
voilà trouver créer des de la croissance
dans certains services en détruisant
moins la planète tu vois quand par
exemple certains me disent bah
maintenant la vie de demain c'est quoi
c'est que tu vas prendre l'avion quatre
fois dans ta vie maximum enfin c'est
horrible tu vois ce que je veux dire
c'est c'est quoi comme perspective
pourquoi pas chacun fait ce qu'il veut
moi j'aurais préféré qu'on me dise la
vie de demain ça va être l'avion à
hydrogène tu vois ou là on va donc créer
une nouvelle source de croissance et de
de manière à se à pouvoir se déplacer
sans en détruisant moins la planète
est-ce que tu fais la corrélation entre
croissance et consommation énergétique
ah ben évidemment c'est complètement lié
mais justement moi je pense
qu'aujourd'hui ce qui nous manque ce qui
nous fait défaut hein c'est de c'est ce
qu'on appelle les nouvelles technologies
de l'énergie ça ve dire un sa
technologique voilà évidemment tuux et
nous les français on prend la voiture
électrique aujourd'ui tout le monde veut
une voiture électrique qui l'a inventé à
la base la voiture électrique c'est nous
c'est nous les français dans les années
80 tu te rends compte 80 90 même bien
avant peut-être même bien avant et alors
pour X raisons les premières bagnoles
étaent électriques quand l'image était
encore no que c'est que des voitures
voilà d'aujourd'hui entre guillemets
mais et donc pourquoi on a laissé passer
ça c'est horrible il fallait peut-être
trouver des débouchés pour le pétrole il
y a un problème non mais je pense qu' il
y a eu effectivement le lobing pétrolier
qui a joué et puis moi je me souviens
bon j'étais chez à l'époque j'avais vu
un des pas donner de nom mais un des
dirigeants
deun constructeur automobile français on
pas donner de nom non plus mat non non
non non c'est il est encore là le
constructeur heureusement d'ailleurs et
il m'avait dit moi jeavais donc c'était
à l'époque si tu te souviens le début de
la voiture hbride chez Toyota la Prius
en 80 céit 98 un truc comme ça 99
c'était le début et et donc moi j'avais
été voir il m'avait expliqué c'est
formidable et donc j'avais dit ça en
comité comme ça et donc j'avais sorti ça
tu vois un peu naïvement qu'est-ce que
vous pensez de la voiture hybride et le
patron m'avait répondu donc de ce
constructeur m'avait dit mais ça n'a
aucun avenir ça n'a aucun avenir donc
nous on fait le 10iel propre tu vois ce
que je veux dire bon voilà on VO où on
en est aujourd'hui tu comprends donc
donc voilà donc tout ça pour dire que
oui il faut il faut de l'énergie propre
il faut de l'énergie des nouvelles
technologies de l'énergie il faut miser
au maximum et si on trouve pas mais bien
sûr qu'on va trouver moi je vois tu
connais tu connais la devise des
chercheurs oui c'est il faut chercher
mais on trouve pas souvent c'est
ça ils l'ont fait parce qu'ils ne
savaient pas que c'était impossible que
c'était possible ouais non c'était
impossible parce que si on leur avait
dit c'est impossible il aurait Jama tu
vois j'ai j'ai eu cette discussion
j'ouvre une petite anecdote à parté j'ai
eu cette discussion là avec le le
fondateur du programme spatial français
qui s'appelait jacqu Blamont qui était
un TR très bon un très très bon copain
qui m'a d'ailleurs aidé à faire plein de
choses dans la vie il me disait toujours
il faut que vous appreniez à composé
avec les cons moi si je je n'avais pas
composé avec les cons jamais j'aurais
envoyé des ballons sur Vénus oua il ça
lui a pris 18 ans donc on avait cette
discussion
sur le saut technologique et ainsi de
suite il me disait voilà moi à mon
époque les bagnoles elles consommaient
30 l maintenant ta taille veut nous
faire des voitures à 2 l mais le
problème c'est la démocratisation de
tout ça c'est infini on consomme
beaucoup plus d'énergie même si les
voitures elles font 2 l mais le problème
c'est que c'est est-ce que dans une
société transformant sans
maturité
d'hyperconsommation si on leur donne une
énergie très très bon marché sans avoir
la maturité le respect de la
consommation de ressources qu'est-ce qui
se passe oui mais encore une fois est-ce
que tu es pour une réglementation non
moi je moi je suis contre la
réglementation moi je suis pour la
liberté voilà ça c'est c'est mon côté
libéral entre guillemets mais dans le
bon sens du terme je pense qu'on a on
nous a surtout depuis le corona comme on
nous a enfermé et cetera moi j'ai très
mal vécu cette période on était je pense
que ici tous aussi ouais non mais c'est
dire que au-delà de des puis des
craintes après tu te rends compte qu'on
avait des passes pour rentrer au cinéma
au machin non mais attendez ça je dire
c'est un truc de fou et on s'est laissé
faire personne et quand tu levais le
petit doigt tu te faisis insulter tu te
rends compte d'ailleurs tu parlais des g
femmes il ce ce type de contestation
était réprimé sur les réseaux oui non
mais bon al moi je moi je moi je me suis
vacciné hein parce que de toute façon
moi je voyage beaucoup donc j'avais pas
le choixin mais bon bon je pas pour les
P parce que c'est pas c'est pas mon
domaine mais ce que je dis par là c'est
que tuas eu des effets secondaires ou
pas non non j'ai eu cette chance mais
moi j'ai la fille d'un très bon ami à
moi 16 ans elle a fait deux AVC donc
c'est peut-être pas corélé c'est
peut-être pas corélé j'en sais rien mais
c'est bizarre des AVC à 16 ans deux AVC
d'affilé c'est rare quand même enfin
bref mais ça peut arriver mais bon
toujours estil que on n'en sait rien
mais euh justement c'est c'est ça c'est
ça la beauté de la vie le problème qu'on
a aujourd'hui c'est qu'on veut plus se
faire mal on a peur de tout on a peur de
tout donc évidemment on te dit ben non
ah là on va tu bouges pas de chez toi he
ah mais tu faut mettre mais c'est quoi
cette affaire sois responsable moi je
l'avais dit à beril justement au tout
début en mars 2020 j'avais osé lever le
doigt comme ça dans la Réunion tout le
monde était contre moi j'avais dit mais
excusez-moi mais pourquoi on on ne on ne
on ne on ne dit pas aux gens me menacer
en danger voilà les gens âgés les gens
qui ont des problèmes cardiaques ce que
tu veux de d'asme et cetera de réjeter
ses U et puis les autres il faut
affronter on va on va voir cette maladie
comment ça ah non non non non on en
ferme tout le monde on a pas de masque
attende quoi cette affaire c'est pas un
argument c'est peut-être parce qu'il y a
des séquels neuro dégénérative à long
terme et que il le savait déjà enfin je
vais pas épiloguer parce que c'est pas
mon encore une fois mais ce que je pas
c'est que moi je suis contre tout ça je
suis pour la liberté alors évidemment
pas la la liberté s'arrête ù celle
commence de l'autre faut pas faire
n'importe quoi mais moi ça me fait peur
cet embrigadement c'estàdire que même
d'un point de vue économique c'est super
dangereux et moi je le vois aujourd'hui
on te dit ah ça c'est le nouveau truc Mo
quand je vois les remarques sur ma vidéo
sur mes vidéos YouTube et ça sur ma
chaîne ou ailleurs même quand je suis
dans les médias je vois sur Twitter les
gens ils parlent peut-être même ce soir
ils vont parler j'en sais rien qui dit
faux monsieur toatil la 4 ail 100 %
électrique de 1970 rechargeable à la
maison la
preuve ah bah c'est bien non mais moi je
je l'ai pas eu mais on aurait dû la
continuer on aurait dû la continuer
effectivement ah bah la quelle qu'est-ce
que c'était sympa ah bien il a deux
chevaux
oui on dirait on dirait des vieux des
vieux qui parlent c'est pas bon là ouis
c'est toi qui VI merci tu es
gentil bon allez arrête de me
déconcentrer non non non mais donc ce
que je pas c'est que voilà aujourd'hui
par exemple quand tu dis voilà ce que ce
qu'on vient de dire là oui la dette
publique augmente ses dangereux et
cetera à tes complotistes à tes
proorusses quel rapport quel rapport
j'entend il y a même un économiste dit
oui il y a des gens qui aiment faire
peur c'est leur Gan pin c'est mais
arrêtezv c'est quoi C c'est quoi ces
bêtises ils ont que ça à CER les
pompes du gouvernement c'est ça c'est ça
le but moi je suis pour sauver la France
et si il faut dire les choses ben je je
le dis même si sans lunettes rose et
sans mais même si ça fait pas plaisir au
gouvernement c'est encore une fois c'est
pas qui me donne à manger mais c'est
vrai que tu as des économistes qui sont
nourris par le ouais on va laisser je
vais me faire l'avocat du diable je vais
je vais défendre le gouvernement non
mais moi je l'attaque pas le
gouvernement simplement je dis attendez
vous vous avez les reennes du pays soyez
responsable
continuez pas cette fite en avant et
c'est ce qu'a voulu faire c'est ce que
semble vouloir faire le maire mais je me
demande c'est pas que du marketing c'est
ça le danger et j'ai bien vu dimanchoir
sur TF devais commenter ensuite donc
j'ai regardé j'ai écouté parce que moi
j'arrive plus trop à écouter les
politiques parce que je zappe tout de
suite j'ai du mal mais bref et bon le ma
c'est peut-être le moins grave
d'ailleurs mais et donc mais c'est vrai
que il était mal à
l'aise tu l'as perçu mal à l'aise ah oui
jeai perçu très mal à l'aise très mal à
l'aise c'estàdire que moi je pense qu'
il est est conscient de ce que je dis il
est conscient parce que je lui
d'ailleurs je lui je envoie à Bery mes
publications que je fais toutes les
semaines et cetera il voit parce qu'ils
ont une veille ils savent tout ils
savent tout ils veillent moi ça m'arrive
d'avoir des coups de fil bon bref je pas
rentrer dans le détail pas depuis des
années ça m'arrive d'avoir des coup de
fil d'intimidation truc comme ça des
coup fil d'intimidation oui ça veut dire
on me dit il faut pas dire ça ou bon à
l'époque tu en texist j'ai même un
ministre qui m'a dit je vais vous faire
virer de la texis tu te rends compte à
l'époque et tu as pas porté PL non
pas tu m'as pas viré enfin bon par Rapp
je suis parti de moi-même après quelques
années plus tard mais voilà c'est voilà
c'est si tu veux
c'est le problème c'est que encore une
fois c'est l'indépendance c'est un luxe
moi j'ai cette chance d'être indépendant
nous aussi vous vous aussi c'est vrai
c'est sûr est d'ailleurs entièrement
financé par notre communauté dans notre
communauté allez sur tipi pour que vous
garantissiez notre indépendance c'est
c'est ce qu'il y a de plus important
bien sûr c'est ce qu'il y a de plus beau
l'indépendance n'a pas de prix moi on
m'a proposé de de de ça fait maintenant
donc je cris mon cabinet en en 2007 tu
vois donc ça fait pas mal d'années je
suis indépendant et plusieurs fois on
m'a créé on on m'a proposé des des posts
dans des banques comme j'avais à texis
aur j'ai refusé j'ai refusé je me suis
dit non non ça une fois que tu as goûté
à la liberté et tu et donc moi c'est ça
que tu veux une fois que tu as commencé
à faire bouger tes chaînes d'abord c'est
là où tu sens ta liberté moi moi je
viens des cité HLM je ré une anecdote
privé qui m' arrivé a pas longtemps mon
fils m'a dit maintenant il est il a il a
23 ans passe le bonjour bonjour bien sûr
je suis sûr il il do sûrement écouter et
il m'a dit papa quand même tu tu aurais
pu faire beaucoup plus gagner plus
d'argent et de faire beaucoup plus de
trucs investir plus machin je écoute mon
fils je dis moi je viens des CIT HLM
dorly c'estàdire le meilleur que je
pouvais espérer dans ma vie c'est avoir
un petit pavillon dans dans le vieil
Orly là-bas tu vois à côté de l'aéroport
être prof éventuellement tu vois voilà
j'ai réussi à m'en sortir je dis pas que
c'est pas bien d'habiter à or attention
c'est très bien hein ça te connecte avec
la réalité mais voilà et moi je me
rappelle et c'est ce que je dis toujours
à mes enfants à tout le monde je dis il
faut c'est pour moi c'est important le
problème qu'on a aujourd'hui je pas
donné de nom mais on a des dirigeants
qui savent pas ce que c'est ça donc il
vous parl des agriculteurs il vous parle
de ça ils savent pas ce que c'est il
vous parlle des CIT HLM ils ne savent
pas ce que c'est ils découvrent ah ouais
on c'est bien ils s'intéresse mais quand
tu as vécu le truc ça rien à voir TU
quand tu les vois balader dans les cités
tu as pas l'impression qu'ils vont à
toiri non mais qu'il font une visite
culturelle oui moi je me souviens quand
j'étais quand j'étais petit donc à hor
je t'en parle de ça parce
que je vais ÉIS obligé de faire une bise
à ma mère ah bah vas-y je suis désolé
c'est la première fois que je fais ça en
disant je t'embrasse maman parce que ma
mère connaît très très bien Orly ah et
et et à mon avis c'est elle qui t'a
vacciné ah c'est possible c'est possible
quand éta tout bébé ah c'est possible
c'est possible c'est possible ah ben
ouis al certainement mais alors bonjour
madame
effectivement je t'a on va pas donner le
nom mais bon c'est vrai que tu me
donneras le nom après mais c'est vrai
peut-être je me souviens d'elle parce
que quand quand tu es petit tu te
souviens des dames qui te font les
vaccins tu te souviens des noms je me
rappelle je m'en souviens en tout cas
encore aujourd'hui termine ton non et
donc oui non mais c'est ce que tu dis
moi je me souviens donc j'étais petit
donc des fois il y avait déjà à l'époque
donc à
l'école en primaire quoi tu vois des des
des officiels qui venaient vous êtes
gentils machin vous venez tout ouais
voilà il faut être sympa B voilà on a
l'habitude quoi mais mais bon c mais
mais franchement tois j'ai alors
peut-être parce qu'on était petit j'ai
mais j'ai j'ai quand même une une bonne
image bon il y avait des trucs chauds he
il y avait plusieurs fois le GG qui est
venu il y avait des trucs il y avait des
des des fois rappelle sur les toits des
mecs qui se tirait dessus non il y avait
des trucs des fois c'était c'est pour un
gosse tu vois de de 8 ans 10 ans il voit
ça c'est c'était chaud quand même donc
moi si tu veux pour moi dans quand
j'étais bon jeis du je fais du je pas
faire du Zola mais c'est vrai que voilà
je me disais ah je peux pas rester là
quoi il faut il faut que je m'en sorte
tu vois et j'ai eu cette chance mais
tout le monde tout le monde a pas mais
mais par contre tu vois je je suis pas
mec qui va tu vois je te donner un
exemple quand je au déb ma carrière tu
vois moi je voulais voilà faire faire du
trader machin tu vois gagner beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup d'argent et je lu dis
ça me correspond pas c'est pas mon truc
faire de l'argent avec de l'argent comme
ça c'est pas mon truc et c'est Mo tout
de suite je me suis tourné vers le
métier d'économiste parce que je couvais
que c'était beau de de pouvoir voilà
comprendre mieux l'économie expliquer
l'économie voilà j'ai eu un petit peu un
rôle social le mec qui gagne beaucoup
d'argent il fait de l'argent avec de
l'argent bon c'est quoi le but du jeu je
je reviens sur les ministres qui vont se
balader dans les cités comme leur vie
visite culturelle qui font ça pour se
faire briller à
l'écran c'est mal perçu quand tu es sur
place toute l'année que tu vois des
ministres il te nettoi les rues juste la
veille tu tu vois ce que je veux dire
c'est c'est absolument c'est scandaleux
de faire ça c'est-à-dire qu'il passent
un coup de Ripolin rapidos ils font
leurs images pour le journal de 20h et
ensuite ils se barrent ouais bon ils ont
un service de sécurité c'est c'est digne
de de de de la je dirais pas de la
Banque de France mais pratiquement
bon mais c'est déjà bien déjà ils y vont
c'est déjà bien bon après même si c'est
calculé c'est déjà bien d'y aller il
pourrait ne pas y aller non plus mais
bon mais bon c'est V faut y aller mais
il faut non mais le truc c'est que non
mais Laur n'y va pas mais fais quelque
chose tu comprends on s'en fout qu'
l'important c'est que ça change ça
change le monde aujourd'hui quand on
voit que malheureusement y a des il y a
des jeunes qui sont dans les C vas-y
vas-y
vas-y non non mais et qui qui se tourne
voilà vers l'extrémisme et cetera tout
ça des trucs c'est c'est horrible c'est
c'est pas le but quoi tu vois tu as
envie de moi moi moi ce que je garde si
tu veux des cités c'est qu'on avait on
avait la excuse-moi l'expression on
avait envie de s'en sortir on aimait la
vie on aimait la vie tu comprends on
aimait la liberté voilà tu fétais tu
fétais la galette des rois tu allais
faire Ranou avec tes potes et tu brisais
le Ramadan avec tes potes ouais ouais
mais mais il y avait c'est ça on était
tous ensemble c'était si tu veux c'était
une
communauté multi multiculturel justement
et et on jouit au foot ensemble alors
bon des fois on s'engueulait on dessus
truc comme ça il quand la France jouait
l'équipe de France de foot voilà on
était derrière l'équipe de France tu
vois aujourd'hui j'ai l'impression qu'il
y a plus ça et et je pense que il y a eu
un gros problème aussi bon ça c'est je
je dir par rapport au sujet économique
mais l'économique du social je pense que
l'erreur une grande erreur ça été de
supprimer le service militaire alors
peut-être que un mois c'était trop long
10 mois c'était trop long un an c'est
trop long peut-être on aurait dû faire 3
mois je sais pas mais tu sais moi je me
rappelle quand j'ai service mon service
militaire tu voyais tous les mecs des
cités et tu avais la levé du drapeau le
matin et tac tac tout ça ça ça te donne
quelque chose ça te reste ta vie parce
que tu es jeune tu vois tu es jeune tu
moi j'avais un peu plus tard parce que
j'étais scientifique du contingent donc
j'ai fait le service après mes études et
sans piston d'ailleurs j'ai eu le poste
mais bon peu importe et mais c'était
formidable tu comprends et et là
aujourd'hui il y a plus ça tu vois
d'ailleurs c'est je pense malgré tout
c'est la force des Américains ou des
Chinois et cetera c'est qu'ils sont
patriotes dire ils aiment ils aiment
leur pays tu com voilà et moi moi ce qui
fait beaucoup de peine c'est quand on me
dit ah vous faites du French bashing oui
de de dire la vérité c'est deeven du
French bashing c'est non moi moi
pourquoi je dis ça parce que je veux
qu'on soit je veux qu'on sauve notre
douce France tu vois la France un P
formidable tu donc il faut sauver la
France sinon tu vas la laisser en quel
état la France une responsabilité tu vis
comprends pour nos enfants nos petits
enfants on a une responsabilité que tes
enfants aujourd'hui ils ont envie
d'aller à l'étranger c'est pas normal tu
as créé ta chaîne Youtube je on passe 5
minutes et puis après on revient à notre
sujet tu as créé ta chaîne Youtube pour
rendre ça al liié à ta cité pour pour
pour pour essimer la connaissance c'est
pas ma chaîne Youtube c'est un plus moi
j'ai ça a toujours été entre guillemets
la mission je me suis alors peut-être
j'espère que j'auraai d'autres missions
dans ma vie je suis encore jeune malgré
ce que tu as dit tout à l'heure mais
mais c'est vrai
que oui je pense queune des missions en
tout cas c'est de démocratiser
l'économie ta petite école à or
s'appelit comment alors j'ai eu Marcel
Cachin c'est la petite école et après il
y a Robert Desnos bon c'est des
résistants voilà c'est c'est du temps de
ça c'était le le collège et après le
lycée il y avait de lycée orlyit donc on
allait à tier cétait Guillaume
Apollinaire voilà vas-y je te voilà et
donc voilà tu sais tout maintenant et
d'ailleurs j'allais à pied à chaque fois
peu importe et ma mère a dû voir tes
fesses ah mince ah bon ben c'est pas
grave et et et donc tout ça pour dire
que oui donc donc moi je pense qu'on a
besoin justement de démocratiser
l'économie parce que moi justement
j'assigne une grande responsabilité aux
économiste aussi parce que pourquoi on
n' pas aujourd'hui de culture de l de
culture économique qu'on a à la place
une culture de lutte des classes parce
que justement les économistes il ont pas
fait leur boulot parce que les
économistes voilà ils aiment rentr je
t'ai dis on l'a dit Marc tu on te
comprend trop quand tu parles tu
comprends nous on est des experts tu
mettre une distance avec les gens j'ai
dit à cette personn là bon qui
maintenant un peu âgé mais qui est
toujours dans le circuit je tu as rien
compris tu as rien compris al après bon
si c'est comme ça je te fais pas entrer
dans mon cercle tu vois de qui je parler
je m'en fous de ton cercle parce que le
le le l'important j'ai pas dit de nom
l'important voilà l'important c'est que
on doit aujourd'hui dire les choses tu
comprends et moi ce qui me fait beaucoup
de peine voilà c'est quand on fait du
French machine parce que j'ai juste dit
la vérité non moi j'aime mon pays tu
comprends j'aime la France et et je veux
sauver la France tu vois et et et et
malheureusement aujourd'hui il y a plus
le cas et quand je vois encore pire
quand je vois les jeunes des jeunes des
mecs des femmes des ce que tu veux des
filles le heureusement il j'en vois
d'autres aussi he qui qui mais qui te
disent aujourd'hui non l'avenir il se
ils vont la France un soumise tu vois
truc comme ça l'extrême gauche ils te
disent ouis on va remettre le RSS on va
on va spoiler l'argent vousz c'est quoi
cette connerie moi quand j'étais petit
quand j'étais dans ma cité à chlm
j'avais pas envie de voler les gens
j'avais pas envie de spoier les gens
j'aV envie de les remplacer j'ai envie
de devenir comme eux j'ai envie moi
aussi de gagner ma vie honnêtement et ça
c'est la grande erreur que font les les
dirigeants notamment en France ils te
donnent des aides tiens c'est comme tu
donnes comme tu dit tout à l'heure tiens
on te donne des aides allez tu
laisse-moi tranquille on vaut pas des
aides nous les les les petits mecs dans
les cités ils veulent pas des aides ils
veulent ils veulent vraiment gagner leur
vie les
agriculteurs exactement les agriculteurs
aujourd'hui ils veulent pas des
subventions des aides des machins ils
veulent voilà comme tu l'as bien dit
être respecté gagner leur vie
honnêtement et et comment tu peux aussi
al on va on va on fait des digressions
encore mais tu as le délit de fè selon
ton adresse quand tu remplis un CV alors
maintenant il y a le CV anonyme mais
mais pendant des années quand tu disais
que tu habitais dans une cité tu te
faisais blacklister direct non pas
forcément parce que bonjà les gens ils
savent pas que tu HLM ils voient
l'adresse mais ils savent pas forcément
tu vois non après tu sais tu sais les
ENT entretien moi je dis aujourd'hui moi
je suis pas pour la sélection comment
s'appelle sélection positive là je sais
pas quoi là discrimination positive
voilà je trouvais pas mes mot il est
tard désolé moi je suis pas pour ça
c'estàd que en fait moi je pense que ça
c'est du racisme tu comprends c'est le
mec tu le reçois quel qu'il soit et puis
tu échanges avec lui puis moi j'ai j'ai
embauché plein d'économistes plein de
gens voilà et tu tu vois tu vois de quoi
il est capable tu vois ce qu'il vaut qui
soit mais tout le monde n'est pas comme
toi ouais d'accord mais bon tout le
monde n'est pas comme toi oui certes
mais pour moi dire que alors parce que
je remplis mon quota il me faut tant de
personnes immigré machin c'est quoi
cette affaire c'est c'est pas sérieux tu
comprends aux États-Unis ils font ça
tout le temps quand même euh pas
forcément non aux ÉtatsUnis ce qui
compte c'est le business ça c'est
complètement différent au ÉtatsUnis que
ce qui compte moi je vois aujourd'hui
ils sont fout m même quand tu parles
anglais moyennement ils s'en foutent ce
qu'ils veulent c'est le business c'està
dire tu fais du business bon c'est pas
c'est pas non plus forcément bien moi je
moi tu sais quand j'avais com je quand
j'avais mon mon équipe aux études
économiques la Banque Populaire tous les
matins je faisais le petit déj enfin
quand j'étais au bureau parce que des
fois j'étais avec mes avec mon mon
équipe on faisait les anniversaires on
faisait tout voilà on était voilà et tu
vois c'est il y avait on échangeait tu
comprends donc c'est pas que le business
bien sûr faire du business par contre
quand il faisait des conneries je je
gueulais ça m' arrivrivait mais mais par
contre ce qui compte c'est de d'être
dans une bonne
ambiance c'est de plus en plus difficile
la
France je discutais avec des copains qui
sont qui qui travaillent à l'étranger
des
expats qui ont grandi en cité et et en
zone à éducation prioritaire ils me
disent on est passé à côté de la France
la France va mal les gens sont très
stressés bon c'est un détail c'est une
percep non mais ce ce qui compte c'est
encore une fois de dire la
vérité et quand je dis aujourd'hui quand
je dis quand tu fais bien tu vois de de
me rappeler de donner les les les
chiffres et cetera de dire les dire les
choses comme on l'a fait aujourd'hui qu'
a une croissance faible et cetera qu' a
cette dette qui explose parce que
attention ne révons pas parce que
j'entends certains qui me disent mais on
s'en fout de la dette on va encore
l'augmenter on va donner et cetera ok
mais qui va payer à la fin c'est nous tu
vas augmenter tes impôts on va te piquer
ton éparne on va c'est pas sérieux bon
si ils ont des trucs quand même sérieux
à la France
insoumise je crois pas non non non non
franchement je sais pas peut-être qu' en
a qui écoute non moi si tu veux c'est
bon enfin bon je v pas rentrer dans la
polémique mais ce qui s'est passé
dernièrement on a vu leur vrai visage
non tu peux pas bref mais mais ce que je
pas c'est que au-delà de cela moi j'ai
fait des débats avec Mélenchon il y a
très longtemps déjà quand il était moins
extrémiste peut-être le problème qu'on a
c'est
que je lui dit d'ailleurs je dis
monsieur Mélenchon ce que vous proposez
on l'a déjà fait ça s'appelait l'URSS on
a vu que ça marchait pas alors ça lui a
pas plus c'est sûr mais encore une fois
moi je bien sûr le capitalisme c'est
c'est pas l'idéal c'est évident qu'il y
a des scoris c'est évident qu'il y a des
qu'il a des qu'il a des arnaques qu' y a
des des gens qui G qui profitent du
système c'est évident tout ça bien
entendu c'est sûr que c'est pas c'est
pas le c'est pas les bisounours mais
encore une fois il faut nous on est là
pour l'améliorer ce système le mec qui
te dit je vais tout casser je vais tout
casser ça bon par moi l'imession qu'il
disent quand même çais tout casser ta
perception Mo les a reçu la franceç
insoumise ils disent pas ça j'aimerais
tellement que les gens se mettent autour
d'une table et trouvent un consensus
pour av avancer ensemble tous les partis
on est tellement dans une mais c'est
pourquoi mais pour se faire il faut pas
être dogmatique tu vois parce que le
problème c'est que quand moi je leur dis
tu vois il y a trop de dette publique
non n'importe quoi on s'en fout de la
dette publique voilà moi je j'ai fait
des débats avec eux on la remboursera
pas on s'en fout on la remboursera pas
c'est pas grave mais les intérêts qui
c'est qui les paye ok tu le rembourses
pas et après qui c'est qui va te prêter
de l'argent si tu rembours pas c'est
fini tu es mort tu comprends donc tu as
vu le Venezuela hein on a vu alors voilà
la France insoumise non faut moi je dis
pas que il moi je suis d'accord pour moi
pénésuel ils sont fait un petit peu il
il y a eu des problèmes de guerre
économique de déstabilisation non mais
non mais il y a pas y a pas que cet
exemple moi ce que je dire par là c'est
que on a eu tu sais quand on dit rien
nouveau sous le soleil on a eu des
exemples justement de collectivisme et
cetera on voit comment ça se termine il
y a pas plus beau que la liberté parce
que ces gens là si jamais un jour ils
arriv au pouvoir ben c'est évident que
tu auras pas la liberté que tu as
aujourd'hui tu comprends donc c'est
c'est ça faut pas perdre de vue ça
l'important c'est la liberté et elle est
en danger parce que déjà des mecs qui
qui te prennent la liberté il te nuisent
à ta liberté on l'a vu pendant le corona
alors imagine des mecs question internet
la France insomise proposé dans ses
programmes électoraux aux deux dernières
présidentielles un investissement public
massif en infrastructure pour remplir le
carnet de commande privé donc une
augmentation de la dette évoqué plutôt
pourquoi celat-il effrayé les
néolibéraux non pas du alors déjà moi je
suis pas j'aime pas ce terme néolibéral
ça veux rien dire moi je le je le dis à
chaque fois moi je suis libéral kénésien
ça veut dire je suis pour la liberté
mais c'est pas un ximor je suis pour la
liberté mais avec l'État qui fait de la
protection sociale voilà c'est ça la
force de la France elle est là et
malheureusement c'est galvodé depuis
quelques années mais c'est ça la clé
qu'est-ce que tu appppelle protection
sociale c'estd maintenir un ascenseur
social bien sûr mais ça marche plus tu
vois bien que l'ascenseur il est plus là
il y a même plus d'escalier maintenant
c'est peut-être une échelle et encore
escabo non évidemment il faut
aujourd'hui faire une vraie dynamique et
surtout le problème c'est de restaurer
la confiance le truc on te dit on va
prendre l'argent là parce que on dit oui
et puis on va on va on va la mettre aur
ça c'est pas vrai tu comprends parce que
globalement mais par contre je suis
d'accord le le bon investissement public
oui il en faut mais c'est évident he
mais mais il faut une dynamique et il
faut une transparence tu comprends et le
problème c'est que par exemple j'ai une
question aujourd'hui de France Inter
hier peu importe non c'était c'est
c'était le Parisien peu importe et qui
me disent voilà les profit du CAC40
pourquoi on les c'est pas normal il y a
trop de profit c'est vrai que c'est pas
normal c'estd que globalement
aujourd'hui le le le le le le français
justement qui malheureusement n'a pas de
culture économique suffisante il voit
ces profits du C40 qui explosent et il
voit que qui sont pas super taxés non
mais pourquoi parce que 80 % de ses
profits ils sont fait à l'étranger ils
sont pas faits ici donc ils sont déjà
taxés à l'étranger donc tu pourras pas
les taxer puisquils sont déjà fait à
l'étranger donc c'est laisser faire
croire ça aux Français c'est un mensonge
tu pourras pas les taxer alors après ok
tu peux spolier bon le groupe il va il
va complètement partir de France tu
comprends et par contre quand tu vois
les les vraies entreprises c'està dire
les PME hein je je je montrer le
graphique de la Banque de France enfin
les chiffres de la Banque de France un
plus haut des faillites d'entreprise
depuis 2010 hors micro-entreprise tu
imagines donc c'est ça la réalité de
l'entreprise en France c'est pas les
mecs du CAC 40 eux ils s'en sortiront
toujours pour que ils font leur business
à l'étranger et d'ailleurs on devrait
être fier on dit bon c'est bien c'est
les voites qui qui font le truc donc ça
tu veux c'est un c'est un faux semblant
et moi c'est ça qui me gêne c'est que on
t'oppose une France par rapport à une
une autre non aujourd'hui justement le
problème de la France c'est qu'on a
énormément de dépenses publiques alors
après je dis pas qu' mais qu'ils sont
mal redistribué en terme d'imposition on
est déjà numéro 1 du monde donc
qu'est-ce que les entreprises elles
touchent aussi des subsides hein les
entreprises mais moi mais moi je suis
compre tout ça moi je suis pour si tu
veux c'est très clair j'ai j'ai fait un
livre qui s'appelait gu la France la
thérapie de choc il y a quelques années
je vais en refaire un d'ailleurs je me
tâte parce que là je vais faire un qu
éditions C c'était à l'époque c'était
les éditions du moment mais ça existe
maintenant mais maintenant je fais des
livres avec book Elis c'est moi qui les
produit entre guillemets je les ai auto
produit avec bookéis et c'est formidable
tu les autoédit je les auto édite c'est
formidable parce alors c'est vrai que
c'est pas les grands éditeurs machin qui
me sollicitent à CH c'est honteux de
faire ça tu devrais pas faire ça c'est
pas non moi je pareil moi je la France
d'en bas moi je trouve c'est formidable
déjà tu es maître de ton de ton bouquin
tu as pas le syndrome de l'imposteur non
puis surtout tu garde tes droits
d'auteur ils sont à toi parce que quand
on fait un bouquin avec un éditeur c'est
lui qui a les droits d'auteur il y a
après ils peuTent faire ce qu'il veut
avec he tu vois ce que dire bon pas
faire un livre un film de mes livres
peut-être j'en sais pas mais mais
toujours que imagine un film des livres
de bruit ça pe être le cas j'avais fait
un livre justement qui s'appelit quand
la zone euro explosera où j'avais un peu
racontré justement ma ma vie entre
guillemets depuis l' deeo et de la zone
euro ouis ouais bien sûr al micro un peu
tu me donnes un peu le micro que je
puissou juste termine sur le sur le sur
les mesures que tu as dit que pour parce
queil faut proposer des mesures pour
sauver la France évidemment moi je suis
moi je suis pas pour les subventions pas
pour les aides non il faut c'est la
pression fiscale pour tout le monde tu
comprends et à partir de là pour les
pour les ménages bien sûr les
entreprises tu vois la CSG par exemple
la CRDS c'est des impôts qui ont été
créés par Michel rard notamment en 91
des impôts qui étaient temporaires
soitdisant à l'époque la CSG c'était 05
% maintenant tu es à 172 tu imagines la
folie donc voilà ça tu pèes et tout tous
les ménages ils vont dire ti l'état il
fait quelque chose pour moi il me baisse
mes impôts j'ai plus de revenus tu
comprends pareil pour l'entreprise donc
si tu baisses parce que tout est lié si
tu baisses les impôts tu as plus besoin
de de faire des niches fiscales tu as
plus besoin de faire des subventions
parce que tu es libéré comment il faut
une liberté et toi après donc tu as plus
de croissance donc l'État a plus de
recettes fiscales et il peut faire des
du social et est-ce que ça fait de
l'inflation ça non pas du tout bien sûr
que non pourquoi l'inflation de façon je
voudrais qu'on parle d'économie de
guerre de réarmement c'est un peu
durement par un petit whisky là parce
que là j'ai pas j'ai pas de whisky mais
comm comme non mais pas de promotion
d'alcool à la
télé pas le droit non pas tout de suite
ah d'accord non non je veux dire c'est
pas une promotion whisky ah oui
d'accord bon d'accord ok on a du giolin
ici si tu veux du quoi du Gibolin c'est
quoi ce truc pour les gens qui n'en
veulent un petit peu bon me déconcentre
pas s'il te plaît vas-y donc l'économie
de
guerre l'aspect géopolitique de
l'économie de guerre l'aspect
intelligence économique l'aspect
renseignement économique est-ce que ça
te parle donc économie de guerre quand
tu vois la Russie être passé en économie
de guerre il y a un peu près 8 ans alors
ils l'ont pas vu venir en France parce
que bon ils étaient peut-être occupés
ailleurs et une économie de guerre ça
met combien de temps à ralentir et
est-ce que ça peut ralentir alors il y a
deux choses il y a économie on va dire
en mode guerrier ça veut dire moi non
mais c'est vrai çaà dire en mode
concurrence mondiale si tu veux c'est ça
pour moi une économie de guerre et après
tu as la vraie économie de guerre comme
aujourd'hui quand tu as une guerre en
Russie ce qui se passe et la pareil
l'arnaque sur la Russie non mais
franchement les mecs tont dit mais il y
a pas que Bruno le mer mais bon tous les
Occidentaux ils sont dit on va on va on
va saigner la Russie en leur mettant des
sanctions attention tu vas taxé
proorusse là ouais non mais je m'en fous
non mais non mais je parle pas de la
Russie je parle pour faire ça pour
n'importe quel pays mais en particulier
la Russie mais le problème c'est quoi
c'est que je dis pas que ce qu'a fait la
Russie c'est bien non non je dis pas ça
je dis le fait que tu as dit que les
pays occidentaux donc en gros les
États-Unis et l'Europe on dit on va va
asphixier la Russie parce qu'on va
l'emper empêcher de commercer ça c'est
un péché d'orgueil c'estàdire que et tu
et là tu comprends que les dirigeants
ils ont pas évolué c'est ils croient
qu'on est dans le Monde de 1980 guerre
froide mais non c'està direire que
aujourd'hui qui sont les maîtres du
monde les producteurs de d'énergie et
surtout ce qu'on appelle les pays
émergents d'ailleurs on les appelle tu
vois on les appelle encore émergents en
fait ils sont émergés depuis bien
longtemps par contre nous on immerge tu
vois ce que je veux dire c'est l'inverse
mais ça nous rassure ils sont émergents
mais attends quand donc qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé c'est pas compliqué tu as eu
aujourd'hui donc la Russie qu'est-ce
qu'elle a fait je l'exemple de l'Inde
l'Inde n'achetait n'avait pas accès au
pétrole russe parce que il allait
ailleurs donc comme la Russie est
bloquée donc elle cherche des des des
clients donc l'Inde Mo moi je peux si
vous voulez donc tu vois là déjà on a
pas compris que l'Inde qui pourtant est
un pays ils sont plutôt avec nous tu
vois mais ils s'en fichent complètement
tu vois ce que c'est ça la guerre
économique tu comiens sont des sacrés
commerçants non mais c'està dire non
mais qu'est-ce qu'ils ont fait
donc la Russie leur a vendu le pétrole
malgré les interdictions bon elleur a
vendu effectivement à l'Inde l'Inde l'a
raffiné et le même pétrole elle a
revendu à
l'Europe ah c'est pas AC une petite com
ouais bien bien sûr mais on dit ah non
c'est pas du pétrole russe c'est du
pétrole indien monsieur mais non tu
comprends non mais tu comprends cette
hypocrisie ce que je par là c'est que
moi pour moi il y a pas pire que la
guerre donc moi j'arrive pas encore à
admettre qu'on qu' qu'on est laissé
cette guerre
il fallait tout faire pour éviter cette
guerre parce que là derrière on sait pas
comment ça peut se terminer fallait déjà
la sentir venir non mais c'est ça non
mais le problème c'est qu'encore une
fois on est
voilà dans dans les grands dans les
grands dans les grandes idées les les
grands objectifs et cetera mais ce que
je dire pas là c'est que le le problème
pour de la Russie c'est pareil par
exemple il y a quelques années qui était
le premier exportateur mondial de
blé les Russes non les Français c'était
la France et avec tout ce qu'on a fait
les HR les machins et cetera qui est
devenu le premier producteur mondial de
blé la Russie premierre exportateur
mondial de blé la Russie donc on l'a
laissé devenir tu comprends c'està dire
que c'est ça le problème du d'une
économie en mode guerrier ça veut dire
que bien sûr on va pas faire la guerre
on va pas tuer des gens tu vois pour ça
la semaine dernière j'ai fait un j'ai vu
qui va gagner la guerre économique sur
ma chaî j'ai vu une chronique qui va
gagner la guerre économique alors d gens
dit non mais c'est pas la guerre non
c'est pas une guerre dans le sens on va
pas tuer des gens il y a pas plus beau
que la vie on va pas on va pas prendre
la vie tu comprends ça pour moi il faut
tout faire pour éviter la guerre c'est
tellement horrible la guerre tu
comprends mais à ce moment-là euh par
contre où il y a une guerre économique
tu vois tu connais le le proverbe de la
guerre économique non peut-être vas-y
dis-moi un chômeur coûte plus cher qu'un
mort ouais non mais ça c'est horrible
non mais ça c'est horrible c'est les
principes de la guerre économique tu
crées du chômage chez les autres tu
affaiblis l'état tu lui chopes ses
marchés tu lui chopes ses entreprises
non non tu tu m'as pas compris sur la
guerre quand je dis la guerre économique
ça veut pas dire tuer l'autre ça veut
dire c'est le mot guerre est peut-être
un peu fort c'est la concurrence tu
comprends c'estàd que quand je dis
guerre c'est parce que tu m'as employé
tu m'as donné ce terme mais c'est
vraiment une concurrence tu comprends
moi je parce
que on est dans un monde ouvert et le
problème c'est qu'il faut s'adapter tu
vois et nous on s pas adapté donc
effectivement si tu t'adaptes pas et ben
tu tu tu te fais bouffer tu vois
aujourd'hui quand je vois tu vois tout à
l'URE tu l'as dit lesentre est-ce
qu'elles sont pas assez patriotes non tu
as tellement de pression fiscale en
France tu vas en Irlande tu as pas la en
Chine c'est le pays de la zone euro tu
vois la taux d'imposition il faudrait
pas interdire ça ce dumping fiscal ben
le problème c'est que comment tu peux
interdire ça non moi je dis contraire il
faut oui peut-être mais il faut égaliser
les impôts par le bas tu comprends il y
a trop
d'écart donc c'est là où aujourd'hui il
faut s'adapter parce que encore une fois
moi je donne souvent des exemples par
que moi je moi je c'est du concret et je
et j'ai conseilé pas mal dans de de de
clients entreprise dans ma carrière et
euh et je me rappelle j'avais une fois
comme ça une entreprise marseillaise tu
vois de qui éta qui faisit de la
peinture industrielle petite entreprise
petite une PME donc lui bon tu vois pour
lui la Chine pour lui c'était très loin
tu vois ils imagin et un jour il va un
salon de son métier quoi de son truc il
y a un chinois qui est là son truc ça
lui plaît je pas dans le détail
depuis donc il a fait une jeune vinture
en Chine il cartonne si tu avais fermé
le monde lu il serait resté à Marseille
c'est peut-être bien peutêtre c'est ce
qu'on veut mais tu com c'est dangereux
aussi de fermer les frontières il faut
un juste milieu par contre ce qui est
dangereux c'est quand pour l'agriculture
par exemple quand nous on nous met des
contraintes administratives des
contraintes écolo tout ce que tu veux et
que aux autres produits on leur dit rien
des autres pays on les laisse rentrer ça
là il y a une distorsion de concurrence
tu comprends là c'est là elle est pas
bonne l'ouverture elle est pas bonne
donc c'est ça il faut être sur un pied
d'égalité donc le problème c'est
l'opacité il faut une transparence tu
vois quand par exemple Sarkozi il a fait
une
loi pour permettre aux investissements
Qataris en France d'être complètement
défiscalisé alors tu sa que en France
aujourd'hui toutes les boîtes qu
étrangères quandent en France pendant 5
ans on est par fiscal ouais c'est donc
quand on te dit quand on se gargarise ah
ouais il y a il y a plein
d'investissements en France qui viennent
mais forcément pendant 5 ans tu payes
pas d'impôt sauf que après les 5 ans
qu'est-ce qu'ils font voilà sauf les
entreprises Catarie parce que elle c'est
à après 5 ans parce que toi tu me vois
mais après 5 ans ils se barrent non mais
tu as compris voilà pas tous oui oui oui
c'està-dire que non pas tousement mais
beaucoup donc donc c'est ça le problème
c'est que pourquoi on fait ça c'est veut
dire qu'on est conscient qu'il y a trop
d'impôts en France sinon on le ferait
pas un cade official fait le même cadeau
aux entreprises qui sont en France tu
c'est l'économie c'est du bon sens
c'est pas c'est du bon sens c'est pas de
la la du dogmatisme on dira c'est les
riches contre les pauvres et cetera on
on va tuer l'autre non c'est qu'est-ce
tu pens qu'est-ce que tu penses de ce
monde multipolaire la Russie qui veut se
dédollariser la Chine qui se dédollaris
les échanges entre la Chine et la Russie
plus du tout en dollar ils veulent
dégager le dollar de leurs échanges
alors ça ça si tu veux ça c'est la
prochaine crise alors pas tout de suite
hein chaque crise en son temps d'accord
on va finir celle-là l'autre je pense
c'est dans 10 15 ans parce qu'en fait
c'est si tu veux ce qui tient le monde
aujourd'hui le monde actuel tel qu'il
est c'est le dollar c'estàd tant que les
États-Unis ils ont le dollar et que le
dollar c'est le ce qu'on appelle en
anglais le benchmark ça veut dire la
référence mondiale que tout le monde
passe le dollar passe par le dollar les
Américains risquent rien et donc c'est
comme ça que ça tient le jour où tu as
un concurrent au dollar c'est fini
lesatsunis s'effondre problème c'est
qu'il faut le concurrent et les Japonais
un jour ils l'ont ils on ils ont voulu
dans les années 80 ils ont voulu te
souviens bon on était jeune hein enfin
toi tu étaisis tout petit to d'ailleurs
et et donc et les japonais ils ont parce
qu'à l'époque c'était vraiment la
superstar CIT comme la Chine aujourd'hui
si tu veux et le Japon pensait qu'ils
allaient battre les États-Unis et sauf
que pour les battre il fallait la la la
devise mondiale tu vois et donc il
fallait remplacer le dollar et là rigan
il a eu un coup de génie parce que rigan
c'est lui aussi qui a sauvé l'Amérique
faut pas l'oublier ça aussi tu c'est une
leçon d'humilité le mec c'était un
acteur de cinéma de seconde zone ran
c'est pas un grand acteur le mec il est
arrivé je il est arrivé donc au
président à l'époque quand tu lis les
livres d'histoire de l'époque les
économistes même les policiologues il
disent les Américains ça ils sont
morts ils ont mis un acteur de sérib
comme président ça c'est pour te montrer
qu'ils sont morts sauf que justement le
mec comme il s'était pas grand si tu
veux un grand haut fonctionnaire ce que
tu veux le mec il s'est entouré des
meilleurs il les a écouté et il a sauvé
l'Amérique tu te rends compte ça c'est
un truc de ça c'est important il a sauvé
l'Amérique il a tué l'URSS il a fait le
coup de la gerre des étoiles donc les
Russes ils ont cru que c'était vrai c'é
que c'était faux ils sont fait des
dépenses énormes il y a un film très
bien qui s'appelle Ferell qui montre
comment les Américains qui est très bien
et il a tué le Japon parce que le Japon
qu'est-ce qu'il leur a fait au coup
japonais dit écoutez comme vous êtes les
meilleurs bah il faut apprécier le yen
et donc les japonais c'est acccord du
Louvre et du Plaza ils ont dit dans les
années 80 ok donc le yen est passé de
200 yen pour un dollar à 80 yen pour un
dollar et ça a tué le Japon les Japonais
s'en sont jamais remis donc les
Américains sont restés pr puissance donc
maintenant qui c'est qui arrive les
Chinois sauf que les chinois sont pas
des japonais comme tu le sais et c'està
dire ils vont pas faire la même erreur
ils sont les Chinois moi tu veux j'ai
j'ai eu la chance de rencontrer en en
2000 c vraiment le début de la Chine qui
cartonnait quoi un des patron de la
banque of China qui est un ancien
général il y a beaucoup de généraux
là-bas quiôle les B dem bien pourquoi un
pe c'est un peu comme la CIA avec les
gars femmes voilà exactement et il m'a
il m'a impressionné il m'a montré en
fait le le business plan chinois et tout
ce qu' m'a dit c'est en 2000 on est en
2023 pour l'instant s réalisé et
notamment un truc très important que
nous on comprend pas que les chinois par
qu'on dit c'est communiste non c'est
juste le système qui est communiste mais
c'est les plus grands capitalistes du
monde ils adorent l'argent d'ailleurs
faut aller sais le cas les casinos à
makao tu sais ils ont fait les mêmes
casinos qu'à Las Vegas sauf qu'ils
gagnent trois fois plus d'argent qu'à
Las Vegas ils adorent l'argent les
Chinois et donc bon c'est dire que c'est
paradoxe c'est des communistes mais ils
adorent l'argent bon bref peut-être
qu'un jourf vont l'argent j'en sais rien
mais oh ça c'est gratuit c'est
méchant c'est interdit d'accord non mais
par ce que c'est que et donc la Chine
c'est sont des gens très intelligents
faut pas les sous-estimer et
heureusement pour nous moi je pense
c'est pas des guerriers ils veulent pas
faire la guerre la vraie guerre tu
comprends ça tu le business la guerre
voilà et donc et lui si tu veux et moi
je lui ai dit à l'époque je lui ai dit
mais vous croyez pas qu'un jour il va
avoir une demande de démocratie on est
entre nous parce que il était en France
tu tu dis ça en Chine et tu te fais
arrêter hein mec dit oui oui on il m'a
dit on y pense mais nous on pense queil
faut d'abord augmenter le niveau de vie
des Chinois et tant qu'on augmente le
niveau de vie des
Chinois la dictature tiendra et donc il
m'avait donné il un truc incroyable à
l'époque il y avait à peu près 100
millions de Chinois qui vivaient
correctement ça veut dire comme nous les
Européens aujourd'hui il y a 650
millions de Chinois qui vivent comme
nous tu imagines en en moins de 20 ans
alors c'est vrai qu'il y a encore donc
900 millions euh 700 millions qui les
lignes de métro qu'ils ont développé les
routes les barrages ils ont compris et
d'ailleurs tu as com tu as vu que avec
le corona parce que ils les ont enfermé
les pauvres chéries bref c'était
horrible ils se sont arrêtés net parce
qu'ils ont compris que ça allait péter
parce que comme l'économie ne
redémarrait pas le chômage commença à
augmenter et donc le niveau de vie
n'augmentait pas vous avez pas le
système de soins pour pouvoir gérer
correctement les choses le niveau de vie
parce que qu'est-ce qui fait tenir un
pays et ça c'est valable pour nous c'est
si tu penses que tes enfants vont mieux
vivre que que toi moi si tu veux c'était
la phrase que me disait mon père il me
dit toujours moi ce que je veux c'est
que mon fils il vit mieux que moi tu
comprend et c'est ça qui fait tenir un
pays donc c'est ce qui fait tenir la
Chine aujourd'hui comment c'est dire le
fait de dire or qu'aujourd'hui qu'est-ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui quand tu vois
les les les jeunes c'est les parents et
les grands-parents qui doivent les aider
qu'est-ce qu'il faisaient tes parents
mon père il travaillit aux impôts é
fonctionnairees ma mère était vendeuse
dans un magasin bon après elle s'est
arrêté quand je suis né donc voilà elle
était femme au foyer t'aidé à faire tes
devoirs le soir ah ouais bien sûr ou
ouais bien sûr mes parents aussi mais
même mon père il faisait bcher non mais
moi je non moi j'ai j'aiis travaill de
moi-même je rappelle à l'époque il y
avait beaucoup de récitations maintenant
il y a plus ça aujourd'hui il fallait
que je bref pas c'est que à partir pour
sur la Chine donc les Chinois si tu veux
eux il savent que eux leur but c'est de
devenir la première puissance mondiale
mais donc ils feront pas la même erreur
que les japonais ils sont pas prêts
parce que pour concurrencer le dollar et
c'est l'erreur qu'on a fait nous les
Européens il faut une devise forte sauf
que pour avoir une devise forte il faut
une économie forte parce que comme nous
on a fait on a eu un euro trop fort ça a
tué la zone euro si tu as une un une
devise forte il faut avoir les reins
solides et les chinois ils sont pas
encore prêts d'ailleurs je sais pas si
tu te
souviens après là dernièrement
là Poutine a été voir zjingping et moi
j'ai eu peur de cette réunion là parce
que je me suis dit c'est la troisè
guerre mondiale puis il est revenu après
le 7 octobre he é bref
et comment dire Poutine est revenu chez
lui il s'est rien passé enfin parce que
Jing ping il veut pas faire la guerre ce
qui compte pour lui c'est que son
économie elle soit florissante et là
l'économie chinoise elle souffre ils ont
du mal à retrouver une croissance forte
c'est l'Inde qui cartonne c'est plus la
Chine et donc ça c'est ce qui nous sauve
de la troisème guerre mondiale c'est que
les Chinois ce qui compte avant tout
c'est que de faire du business d'avoir
une économie mais par contre un jour
peut-être dans une quinzaine d'années si
si les Américains continuent comme ça et
bien ils vont se faire battre par les
Chinois sur le terrain économique alors
je te parle même pas de la zone euro je
sais même pas si sera encore là dans 15
ans mais toujours pour dire toujours
estil que là les les Chinois le jour où
ils ont battu le le dollar c'estàdire
que le Yan ça devient la monnaie
mondiale al là c'est une catastrophe
mais c'est pas pour maintenant les
chinois sont pas prêts tu as une
confiance un peu dans l'euro la zone
euro ou si tu veux moi moi je vaisêtre
très honnête je vais être très honnête
moi j'aiand donc tu sais je sais pas si
tu te souviens bon donc j'ai participé à
la de la zone j'étais à la Banque
Populaire à l'époque c'était euphorisant
cé exceptionnel c'està-dire que surtout
pour une banque parce que en fait il y
avait vraiment des challenges énormes
d'un point de vue informatique d'un
point de vue technique et cetera je me
rappelle et c'est vrai que j'y ai cru je
dois avouer que j'ai cru que l'euro
allait concurrencer le dollar j'ai cru
qu'on aller faire une vraie zone euro si
tu veux voilà crédible sérieuse puis
malheureusement mes mes espoirs ont été
déçus et donc maintenant bah on col mat
les brèches faut être honnête et donc je
je je ce qui qui est sûr c'est que si la
zone euro
explose ça sera très très compliqué
parce que souvent on me dit le brexit
moi j'étais l'un des rares à dire que le
brexit ça allait pas être une
catastrophe pour le Royaume-Uni parce
que les anglais sont très malin anglais
là comment il est ben les Anglais ils
s'en sent bien he c'est je l'ai montré
bon ils ont fait une récession comme un
peu plus forte que nous mais quasiment
comme nous mais par contre en terme de
PIB je donne le chiffre dans ma vidéo de
cette semaine incroyable depuis 2015 le
PIB britannique a augmenté plus que le
PIB français
et oui tu vois pourtant ils ont le
brexit ils ont eu le corona comme nous
mais bon nous on appelle brexit mais
mais la les Anglais déjà c'est des gens
aussi assez malin je pense et assez
réactifs des anglo-saxons et puis
surtout bon ils ont les accords avec les
États-Unis le Common Wells et cetera
mais surtout eux ils ont pas changé de
devise ils avaient la Liv stling donc
par contre nous on a l'Euro donc si
demain on fait un ce que certains
demandent un frxit ça veut dire qu'il
faut il faut reprendre le le franc et là
ça va être compliqué tu vois donc c'est
c'est pas c'est c'est rien à voir autant
le brexit je pense a été gérable il a
été bon mon avis c'est quand même une
erreur je pense parce que les Anglais
ils s'arrangeaient toujours avec
l'Europe ils s'arrangeaient il y avait
ce qu'on appelait à l'époque le chèque
anglais pour que les Anglais ils
imposaient tous les ans de récupérer la
même somme qu'ils avaient donné à
l'Europe je sais pas si te souviens de
ça et donc bon ce qui a gêné les Anglais
il faut être honnête c'était la
réglementation européenne et donc là
c'est vrai que l'Europe c'est devenu une
outil une usine réglementation c'est pas
ça l'Europe pour moi l'Europe c'est
normalement ça aurait dû être une terre
de croissance forte on a fait l'euro
pour concurrencer les États-Unis puis on
n arrive pas donc fauttre h et nous
parce que nous aussi les Français on a
déconné on n pas sérieux sur notre dette
publique et puis surtout la zone euro
est trop grosse trop grande 20 pays qui
n'ont rien à voir ça c'est un concept
important la zone euro ce qu'on appelle
normalement ça doit être ce qu'on
appelle une zone monétaire optimale ça
veut dire parfaitement intégré avec une
harmonisation des conditions fiscales et
réglementaires sauf qu'on a des pays
complètement différents avec des
dumpings fiscaux et cetera donc ça
marche pas donc c'est c'est pour ça
j'avais écrit un livre il y a quelques
années qui s'appelle donc quand la zone
euro explosera non pas que je le
souhaite mais si on continue comme ça
c'est inévitable alors moi je suis pas
pour une explosion parce que là ça fera
très mal parce que il faut bien prendre
conscience hein je al peut-être que ceux
qui nous écoutent ils sont pour je sais
qu'il y a des abonnés de ma chaîne qui
sont pour le frxit et cetera mais je
leur dis faut bien comprendre que si il
y a plus la zone euro
les taux d'intérêt de la dette publique
française c'est pas à 3 % qui vont être
c'est à 10 % ça il faut le savoir alors
après bon on pe on peut dire c'est pas
grave on va fermer les frontières tout
ira bien peut-être peut-être qu'après ça
ira bien j'en sais rien mais mais on va
morfler ça il faut le savoir ça il faut
le savoir donc après moi je suis plus
pour une zone euro à deux vitesses
c'està-dire une zone euro avec des pays
qui le mérite qui respecte les règles
donc qui ont un euro on va dire fort
puis notre zone euro peut-être on sera
dedans d'ailleurs mais qu'ils ont l'euro
toujours parce que tu imagines si on
reprend les Francs faire les billets les
machins oui oui c'est compliqué hein euh
et et à ce moment là avec mais et qui
respectent pas les règles et tant que tu
respectes pas les règles tu rentres pas
dans la vraie zone euro voilà c'est
c'est c'est clair on change de on change
totalement faire tard là ça fait
1h51 ah non ça va on on est dans les
temps ça va ti tu as soif tu as soif
c'est ça pe soif c'estve tu tiens le
choc ouais et on revient à question
basique tu as vu le le niveau d'apport
personnel quand tu souscris un emprintt
immobilier il était très fort il a
baissé énormément de 20 % à 40 %
et pour certaines villes ou certaines
banques ou certains endroits tu tu lis
ça comment tu lis ça comme les banques
ont peur que le marché d'immobilier se
casse la figure donc elles font tourner
les assiettes un peu plus
facilement tu vois ça comment alors déjà
un truc important l'immobilier avec la
bourse et l'or ce sont les trois
meilleurs placements voilà donc on donne
PAS de conseil financiers non non non
non je je pas c'est pas un conseil ça
c'est une réalité c'està dire que j'ai
fait une étude il y a quelques années
euh où j'avais justement fait sur mais
c'està dire sur euh sur 100 ans cedrico
il a pris 170 balles d'action dans une
start-up là il récupère des millions
hein ouais non mais sur 100 ans même si
tu investis en haut des bulles sur long
terme tu es toujours gagnant dans
l'immobilier la bourse l'or alors
peut-être un jour ça va changer hein
mais voilà mais bon ce que je c'est que
et et mais par contre il y a des bulles
boursières des bulles sur l'or aussi
parfois et des bulles immobilières donc
là tu te rends compte que depuis 2016
entre 2016 et 2022 les prix de
l'immobilier français en moyenne
augmenté de 35 %. c'est énorme donc tu
avais des prix qui n'avaient plus aucun
sens et ça c'est à cause du corona enfin
à cause de la la planche habillée on a
fait tout intérêt à zéro donc tu dis au
ça coûte rien endettez-vous sauf que
attention et ça c'est très important là
je peux donner un conseil de vie quand
même c'est que pour les jeunes notamment
la première chose à laquelle il faut
penser quand on est jeune bon bien sûr
c'est RRA c'est non non non non pas pas
tout de suite d'abord il faut kiffer la
vie d'abord ça c'est important ça faut
pas faut pas et voilà et c'est d'acheter
sa résidence principale ça c'est très
important parce que quand on voit les
études qui sont faites hein notamment en
France la plupart des gens qui
malheureusement au 3è âge tombent dans
la provetteré dans la pauvreté il y en a
de plus en plus ce sont ceux qui n'ont
pas leur résidence
principale quand tu as ta résidence
principale c'est tu l'as acheté tu as
mis ta vie à l' acheté mais tu elle est
à toi tu es protégé ça veut pas dire que
tu rolles sur l'UR mais tu es protégé
donc ça c'est un objectif de vie je
pense B après chacun fait ce qu'il veut
hein et et voilà le problème c'est que
euh là on avait des prix qui avait donc
à cause de d'intérêt trop bas qui ont
complètement flambé si bien les jeunes
ils pouvaient plus acheter non mais je
te rassure ils peuvent toujours pas
acheter hein ouais voilà bien sûr c'est
pour ça que la baisse des prix est est
nécessaire la baisse des prix de M c'est
pas une mauvaise nouvelle ça permet de
relancer de ressolvabiliser la demande
et donc là aujourd'hui tu vois les
promoteurs immobiliers ils sont à la
gorge si les prix baissent donc tu vas
avoir plus de demande et donc tu vas
pouvoir redémarrer les taux d'intérêt
ils vont rester élevés ils vont un petit
peu baisser d'ici la fin 2024 début 2025
donc ça pourra redémarrer donc voilà et
donc c'est ce qui fait aujourd'hui que
il faut Ster mais attention pas à
n'importe quel prix c'est-à-dire que
quand tu tendêes aujourd'hui parle le
gouvernement il a dit maintenant tu tu
as le droit dealler jusqu'à 35 % de ton
revenu faire faut faire attention parce
que malheureusement ce qui va se passer
là ça commence déjà c'est que il y a
beaucoup de Français qui se sont
surendettés qui malheureusement le
chômage augmente tombe au chômage ils
peuvent pas rembourser leurs
endettements et ils vendent leur appart
à bas prix tu comprends et c'est ça qui
est très dangereux donc c'est pourquoi
il faut aujourd'hui il faut s'endêter
mais quand même il faut réfléchir tu
comprends donc il faut il faut se dire
voilà si aujourd'hui j'ai tel train de
vie on va dire et et quand je vais
m'endetter ça va je vais plus pouvoir
avoir la même vie ça va bon il faut un
juste milieu question
internet bonsoir Monsieur Tati quel est
l'intérêt d'un indicateur comme le P
dans le monde dans lequel on vit
aujourd'hui pauvreté et
augmentation dépassement des limites
planétaires dérèglement climatiqu qui
s'intensifie les conditions d'existence
des activités économiques disparaissant
petit à petit mais ont continue à
focaliser notre attention sur le PIB
quelle est la logique du raisonnement
alors non mais je suis entièrement
d'accord ce qu' VI dit c'estàdire
évidemment c'est la pauvreté pour moi
c'est le plus important et d'ailleurs
pour moi le PIB c'est pas la pauvreté
c'est c'est relatif non ce dire la
pauvreté bien sûr c'est relatif mais
c'est l'évolution de la pauvreté ce qui
aujourd'hui moi me fait très peur en
France si tu veux c'est le le
déclassement c'estàd la classe moyenne
qui fait la richesse d'un pays la classe
moyenne se délite elle s'appauvrit ça
c'est dangereux com mais donc je reviens
sur la question évidemment que le PIB
c'est pas le but en soi le but pour moi
c'est l'emploi et le bien-être
économique mais on peut pas avoir
d'emploi et de bien-être économique et
et de baisser la pauvreté sans revenus
sans PIB tu comprends donc c'est vrai
que si le c'est comme on dit l'argent
n'est pas le but l'argent est un moyen
mais c'est pareil le PIB le PIB c'est
pas le but donc le pb c'est la richesse
qu'on crée c'est pas le but mais c'est
un moyen et puis après le problème c'est
que c'est le seul pour l'instant
peut-être ça va changer un jour mais
c'est le
seul indicateur on va dire harmonisé au
niveau mondial qui nous permet de faire
des comparatifs au niveau mondial voilà
et donc et et ce qui ce qui permet
effectivement de pouvoir comparer les
différents différents pays donc c'est
pourquoi on l'utilise encore
malheureusement on a pas mieux moi je
veux bien si d'ailleurs je j'ai souvent
cette question je dis si vous avez mieux
moi je prends parce que c'est vrai que
le bouton avait créé un indicateur de
bonheur économique vous AES entendu ça
mais le bonheur c'est très subjectif tu
comprends donc mais c'est sûr qu'il
faudrait l'améliorer ce niveau mais le
problème c'est que comme disait euh
Churchill hein j'ai confiance dans les
statistiques uniquement si c'est moi qui
les ai faites c'est-à-dire que
évidemment si c'est toi qui fait la
statistique tu vas tout faire en sorte
pour qu'elle soit euh euh à ton avantage
ça s'appelle du window dressing euh
exactement donc donc c'est pourquoi je
suis d'accord sur le fait que c'est pas
le meilleur indicateur pour l'instant on
a pas mieux mais par contre c'est vrai
qu'il faut pas le voir comme un but
c'est un moyen de faire d'avoir de
l'emploi d'avoir du revenu d'avoir du
bien-être économique question Internet
est-ce que la trajectoire budgétaire
allemande ne va pas rejoindre celle de
la France vu la crise énergétique et la
désindustrialisation alors oui c'est
enfin ils s'en sont loin c'està dire que
pour l'instant ils sont à ils ont une
dette publique à 60 67 % de leur PIB
nous on est à quand même 112 et bientôt
115 donc ils ont de la marge hein
d'ailleurs ça c'est important de le dire
c'estàdire
que il y a beaucoup de pays aujourd'hui
qui sont faiblement endettés ça le donne
une marge de manœuvre énorme
pour justement relancer la machine ce
que nous n'avons plus nous on a plus
cette marge de manœuvre donc c'est vrai
que les Allemands aussi ils ont fait bon
l'erreur qu'ils ont fait c'était de
d'arrêter le nucléaire faut être honnête
c'était une erreur historique comme les
Japonais quand ils ont voulu apprécier
leur le leur Yenne c'est pareil les
Allemands qui pourtant étaient quand
même assez intelligents c'est vrai he
ben là ils sont plantés ben voilà et
c'est vrai qu'ils ont ils ont ils ont
pas fait notre erreur c'estd ils ont
gardé une forte industrie ça céit une
des chances de l'Allemagne si veux que
notre grande erreur à nous les Français
c'était dans les années 80 90 ce qui
était un choix stratégique politique
donc une erreur stratégique évidemment
qui avait été de d'annuler l'industrie
on avait dit à l'époque on va avoir une
économie française sans usine ça c'était
un choix une erreur dramatique éidemment
alors maintenant on dit oui on va
réindustrialiser ah c'est super oui
bonne idée qu'un faucon mais comment on
fait il y a plus il y a plus sans
énergie sur il y a plus de main d'œuvre
tu vois donc ça a été effectivement
l'erreur des Allemands donc je pense que
effectivement va mal moi par contre je
pense que j'auraai la question inverse
c'estàd c'est vrai qu'on se dit benah si
les Allemands vont mal donc ils vontins
ils vont nous lâcher la grappe mais non
c'est l'inverse je sais pas moi je suis
pas germanophone je lis pas l'allemand
mais je je je lis la presse allemande en
anglais c'est très intéressantou et moi
ça m'arrive je suis à peu près une
conférence par an à
Francfort et et donc je vois comment
évolue le public parce que c'est des
Allemands qui sont en face de moi et ils
peuvent plus nous supporter les Français
hein quand tu lis la presse allemande tu
vois que ils sont très très méchants à
notre égard et on peut les comprendre tu
veux les mecs qui sont serrés la
ceinture pendant depuis des années et
nous on joue les cigales et on se ramène
donc ça il supporte plus et et moi je
pense que les Allemands j'avais fait un
papier comme ça il quelques années
j'avais écrit ça je d c'était à l'époque
de la crise grecque j'avais dit le
problème c'est pas le grexit c'est veut
dire parce qu'on avait peur que la Grèce
qui la zone euro donc c'est pas le
grexite c'est le gerxite ça veut dire
Germanie exite c'est dire moi je pense
c'est les Allemands qui vont quitter la
zone euro parce que enfin en l'état
parce qu'ils vont dire attendez les gars
on en peut plus de votre truc on est
plus d'accord avec ce que vous faites
ouais mais sans le gazau du crus ils
vont moins faire les malins ah ben
évidemment évidemment évidemment mais ça
c'était comme tu le sais très
bien tu connais l'histoire ça on en
parle pas trop je sais pas si on peut le
dire mais sur le la campagne contre le
nucléaire allemande qui a été financée
par Gazprom comme tu le sais he donc
voilà donc les les Allemands se sont
rendus eux-mêmes dépendants du gaz russe
faut pas l'oublier tu vois c'est un
c'est un choix stratégique se sont
passés la laisse au coup exactement
question internet c'est pas le Bitcoin
qui depuis 10 ans sur performe tous les
assets financiers confondus point
d'interrogation depuis 10 ans moi je par
depuis 100 ans ça existait pas le BIT tu
avis tu as un avis sur les
cryptos le problème c'est que les crypt
c'est devenu une religion si tu veux
c'est vrai c'est tu soit pour soit
contre les extrémistes les machins ou là
là moi j'ai chaque fois que j'ai fait
des chroniques des vidéos sur le Bitcoin
oh là là les messages que j'ai eu
c'était mais c'était violent moi je
bloque quand j'ai m comme ça méchant je
bloque parce que ça sert à rien je peux
pas discuter des gens qui
sont écoute moi si tu veux le Bitcoin
moi aussi je l'ai vécu à sa création et
c'est vrai que je m'en veux parce que
j'en ai pas acheté c'est vrai moi
j'aurais pu en acheter à zé ENF un
dollar tu aurais pu même les faire
toim-même ouais exactement et et
pourquoi je l'ai pas acheté parce que en
fait j'étais persuadé que les autorités
allaient
légiférer
je me suis dit il vont pas laisser faire
un truc pareil c'estàd que il y a aucun
contrôle il y a il faut le dire
peut-être beaucoup de cryptonnaie qui
sont des fausses monnaeses c'estàd qu'
sont des sont des arnaques hein il y a
beaucoup qui sont des qui sont utilisés
pour financer la mafia le terrorisme et
cetera faut dire faut être honnête hein
donc moi ça ça me gênait de pas savoir
qui j'ai en face de moi dans ch je te
vois en face de moi je sais avec qui je
discute là je sais pas qui j' facei
après par contre c'est vrai qu'il y a un
aspect technologique de la blockchain
qui est formidable qu'on peut pas nier
tu vois mais moi je me suis dit ils vont
légiférer ils ont pas ils ont pas
légiféré ils ont laissé faire et ça j'ai
c'est vrai et d'ailleurs je m'excuse he
pour ceux à qui j'ai dit n'achetez pas
de Bitcoin et qui en ont pas acheté
comme moi hein j'ai fait la mer pas de
conseil de d'inves non que je je
m'excuse j'ai pas dit que je pour que tu
me demandes la question sur le sur le
Bitcoin et donc aujourd'hui quand on me
dit put j'ai eu un message aujourd'hui
on me dit alors euh tu tout il faut
acheter du B j'en sais rien voilà je moi
je suis honnête quand je je met je dire
quand je fais des prévisions sur la
bourse par exemple c'est parce que je
regarde les profits la croissance donc
je fais des prévisions là sur quoi je
faire mes prévisions sur Bitcoin sur le
l'achat l'offre et la demande je la
maîtrise pas tu comprends alors c'est
sûr que ça peut monter très haut ça peut
baisser très bas ce qui est sûr c'est
que c'est dangereux c'estd que c'est le
couple rendement risque donc ça peut
rapporter énorme mais quand ça rapporte
énorme c'est que tu as un risque énorme
donc voilà c'est ce que je peux dire
c'est maintenant euh
voilà je pense qu' je vais raconter une
anecdote rapidement justement il après
une conférence dernièrement il y avait
un donc une confance économique il y
avait un papa et son fils papa qui
devait avoir mon âge je pense et son
fils qui doit avoir l'âge de mon fils
c'est du autour des 20 22 23 ans et donc
le papa vient vient me voir il me dit
voilà écoutez j'ai j'ai j'ai perdu 6
j'ai acheté des
cryptoonnaies j'ai perdu je pas 80 % de
la valeur le pauvre chéri tu vois bon
c'était sa retraite quoi le mec et euh
et donc mon fils qui est ici présent il
me dit que il faut que je remette le peu
qui me reste il veut que je remette donc
le fils oui ou ça va ça va cartonner ça
va redémarrer je écoute toi tu es jeune
tu tu peux te permettre de perdre lu
pauvre chérie c'est sa retraite tu
comprends donc moi je dis tu peux le
faire mais sache c'est dangereux donc
voilà moi je voilà je j'irai pas plus
loin parce que encore une fois
technologiquement c'est formidable les
les autorités n'ont pas légiféré mystère
pour l'instant ouais mais ils feront je
sais pas s'ils le feront je veux dire
c'est c'est c'est un vrai mystère ils
peuvent pas ils peuvent pas se permettre
de perdre le contrôle de leur propre
monnaie mais c'est pas attention le
Bitcoin n'est pas une monnaie ça ça
c'est le c'est le c'est pas quand tu dis
cryptoonnaie merci de meendre et oui non
c'est non c'estd il y a y a un abus de
langage c'est pas une monnaie c'estàdire
une monnaie il y a elle est basée sur
quelque chose sur une réalité économique
sur sur un pays sur la et là il y a pas
donc il y a une confiance dans une
communauté très bien donc en fait si
dans ta communauté a confiance il y a
pas de problème mais après tu tu tu
au-delà de C tu peux pas tu peux pas
être sûr tu comprends
déjà les monnaes où il y a où il y a des
états derrière des banques centrales
déjà c'est borderline alors imagine là
il y a personne mais c'est le but du jeu
tu veux qu' personne justement donc pour
que ça sera pas légifér tu parles de
banque centrale de Borderline pourquoi
et qu'est-ce que tu penses de Christine
Lagarde tu m'as dit faut pas dénigrer
c'est c'est compliqué tu me poses des
questions j'aime beaucoup Christina
garde don une and bien habillé c'est ça
oui mais je vais même te dire moi c'est
elle donne de bons conseils et elle a
stabilisé la zone viment moi je trouve
c'est c'est c'est vraiment une femme
très compétente enfin c'est non c'est
dire c'est une
femme qui a de la valeur voilà c'est je
peux me permettre de parler ainsi je je
te donner une anecdote qui m'est arrivée
avec elle en tout bien tout honneur je
te rassure elle a été nommée secrétaire
d'État au Commerce extérieur par Jacques
Chirac à l'époque il y a très longtemps
et elle m'a appelé à l'époque elle m'a
dit voilà écoutez moi je suis une
avocate d'affaires donc je connais bien
les relations internationales mais par
contre l'économie c'est pas trop mon
truc donc ce que comme je vois que vous
c'est votre métier parce que vous ça
vous init de me donner quelques conseils
quelques cours je suis allé gratuitement
à Mercille j'était et c'était voilà et
elle m'a remercié c'était super
voilà voilà donc sauf que bon elle a pas
compris toutes mes courses j'ai
l'impression non ce que dis pas c'est
que pourquoi les banques centrales c'est
bordur mais les banques centrales quand
même c'est des pompiers
pyoman êre honnête c'estàdire
que Madame Lagarde elle a quand même dit
en 2022 dans une interview comme ça
l'inflation vient de nulle part c'est
quand même énorme c'està dire c'est
c'est toi qui la BCE qui doit maîtriser
l'inflation tu dis elle vient de nulle
part ça donne pas hyper confiance quoi
tu vois même dans les mots faire
attention à ce que tu dis et non moi je
pense que la politique monétaire c'est
très complexe et et c'est pas facile je
dis pas que c'est facile et moi je pense
je pense que elle était mieux à l'UR
ministre d' l'économie ou FMI la Banque
centrale européenne c'est c'était pas
son truc mais bon et et et je pense
qu'il y a
eu l'erreur fondamentale c'était de
continuer la planche à biller alors que
l'inflation commençait à arriver on
était en 2021 moi je l'ai dit
l'inflation arrive on m' rie au nez et
surtout on a continué la planche à Bill
on n' pas augmenté les taux d'intérêt et
comme je le dis souvent l'inflation
c'est comme le dentifrice une fois qu'il
est sortie du tube tu peux pas le
remettreon tu fais un petit choc
volkerur ouais donc non mais mais mais
choc volkerur c'est c'est c'est c'est
c'est pour ceux qui qui s'en souviennent
c'est c'est les années 80 c'estd c'est
c'est une récession dramatique donc et
c'est ce qui en train de se produire
aujourd'hui et donc le problème c'est
qu'à l'époque
alors on me dit que en fait c'était pour
justement qu'on a continué à
plancheabiller jusqu'en aux élections
françaises de 2022 extrémisme voilà pour
continuer voilà j'espère que c'est pas
le cas parce que si c'est le cas c'est
grave mais a priori c'est le cas donc
c'est grave tu vois donc voilà j'en veux
un petit peu à madame la garde à cause
de ça parce que je pense que on a perdu
du temps non surtout on ben on a fait
une erreur une erreur qui nous coûte
cher parce que tu as fait la planche à
trop longtemps donc tu as laissé
l'inflation s'installer après tu arrivé
la guerre en Ukraine et tu as pas tu as
laissé l'inflation devenir on a commencé
à réagir quand l'inflation elle était à
à 10 % quand même 11 % même il est monté
dans la zone euro c'est un peu tard tu
vois et donc après tu cours derrière le
train donc tu le rattrapes jamais et
donc on a dû monter les taux d'intérêt
beaucoup trop fortement donc ce qui a
vraiment généré une récession qui va
risque d'être douloureuse et donc
maintenant pour baisser le T d'intér ça
va être un petit peu compliqué tu vois
une politique monétaire c'est c'est ce
qu'on appelle contracyclique ça veut
dire tu dois anticiper ce qui va se
passer et malheureusement ça n'a pas été
le cas donc voilà doncant maintenant
elle gère elle gère voilà elle gère la
situation mais à cause de cette erreur
bon il y a pas qu'elle qui a fait
l'erreur mais les américains ils ont
réagi quand même dès la fin 2000 2021 et
début 2022 donc ils ont compris ils ont
fait aussi la même erreur en 2021 mais
fin 2021 il dit on arrête Arte la
planche habillé ça y est mainant on
arrête on va remonter les taux ils ont
monté t début 2022 et ça a marché parce
qu'ils ont monté les taux é une petite
récession et hop ça redémarré que nous
on a justement ne pas avoir une
récession
finalement une récession qui qui va
durer tu vois c'est sauf que tu as pas
touché le fond de la piscine quand tu
touches le fond de la piscine tu
rebondis que nous nous on veut pas on
veut pas se faire mal encore une fois on
veut pas se faire mal donc on raque le
fond de la piscine ce qui évidemment n
peut nous coûter très cher petit
commentaire je suis doctorantalis en
léisl pardon en législation Union
européenne sur les cryptos le CO le coût
juridique est bienvenu en 2023 au moins
en Union Européenne voir la légalisation
my notamment mar euh c'était juste un
commentaire question internet bonsoir
l'argent n'éant qu'un rapport de
confiance où se situe le point de
rupture et à quelle vitesse nous y
approchons ça c'est c'est c'est une
question essentielle c'està dire
qu'effectivement tu l'as bien dit donc
c'est enfin l'auditeur l'a bien dit la
la la la monnaie effectivement repose
sur un contrat de confiance et donc ce
contrat de confiance ça veut dire qu'il
y a du sérieux que tu crois en tes
institutions donc c'est ça qui est
dangereux tu crois voilà en le fait que
si je prends le cas de la France la
France va réduire ses dettes publiqu
elle le fera enfin elle le fait pas elle
le fera pas tu crois que la BCE elle va
contrôler l'inflation elle l'a pas fait
je te rappelle que l'objectif la BCE en
fait elle a un objectif unique
d'inflation à 2 % on est monté à 11 donc
la confiance personne n' été
virée surtout il y a il s'est passé un
truc si tu te souviens euh en 2020 il y
a la cour de Carles rue donc en
Allemagne comme le consil constitionel
si tu veux qui a dû qui a dit qui a dit
euh qu'en fait on allait
euh que ce que faisait la BCE la planche
habillé c'était contraire à la
constitution allemande et comme c'était
le corona on dit non non non mais
c'esttoi tuis-toi tout va bien tout va
bien ça peut revenir ça non je te dis
les Allemands à mon avis c'est euux qui
vont mettre le haut là
c'est ça va pas continuer comme ça
est-ce que tu as un sujet que tu
souhaites aborder avec nous et notre
communauté ben déjà non j'is je suis
très content d'être parmi vous voilà
j'espère que ça vous a plu et c'est pas
fini fin la conclusion bon les TH y en a
plein qu'est-ce qu' on a tell on parl
beaucoup de choses quand même donc
qu'est-ce qu'on a pas aborder qui te
chauffe sinon tu reviens une prochaine
fois ouais ouais non non non non je on a
parlé de l'inflation non je pense qu'on
a on a peut-être pas parler également un
truc important justement de la formation
très important c'estàd qu'en fait
aujourd'hui le le le le le le chômage
quand on parle de pénurie de main
d'œuvre par exemple il y a un problème
parce que on a plus plus de 6 millions
de chômeurs en France parce que tu sais
tu connais le chômage le comm source non
non
l'INC la DARES en fait tu as la
catégorie a donc la catégorie A c'est le
chômeur labellisé entre guillemets c'est
dire ça veut dire il a pas du tout
travaillé il il fait une recherche
active d'emploi et il est immédiatement
disponible ça veut dire on lui donne un
boulot il va tout de suite ça c'est très
séleect donc quand on te dit le chômeur
à 3 millions de chôin et c'est c'est que
ces gens-là en fait si tu vois tous les
autres chômeurs dire ceux qui ont un
petit peu travaillé ceux qui sont pas
disponibles ceux qui aimeraient
travailler mais qui font pas de
recherche ça tu as plus de 6 millions de
chômeurs chiffre de la
daress tu vois ça veut dire quasiment 17
% de taux de chômage chiffre de l'INC
c'est sorti la semaine dernière donc ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire que tu as
pas de pénurie de maindœuvre normalement
la main d'œuvre elle est là et pourtant
les boîtes elles veulent embaucher elles
y arrivent pas pourquoi parce que tu as
un problème de formation et ça encore
une fois c'est une responsabilité de nos
dirigeant c'est une erreur stratégique
de nos dirigeants notamment au niveau de
l'éducation nationale c'està dire qu'on
a formé pltor de bac+ 5 en histoire de
l'art j'adore l'histoire de l'art alors
je fais attention parce que dis ça dans
une conférence et à la fin quelqu'un
venu me voir dit moi je fais l'histoire
de l'AR mais j'ai du boulot très bien il
a pas de problème mais les débouchés
sont quand même limités tu comprends tu
pens qu'il y a trop de voix de garage
bien sûr évidemment et aujourd'hui et
surtout il y a pas de son métier tu vois
ça c'est mon éducation également mais
mais en France on on a fait on te dit tu
as un bac plus 5 tu es tranquille mais
pas du tout ça dépend de quel bac + 5 tu
as fait et à côté tu as aujourd'hui
parleas tu as des pénuries de soudeur
industrielle tu as des pénuries de
plombier un plombier aujourd'hui il
gagne beaucoup mieux qu'un bac plus 5 tu
coms bon s'il a si bon il a envie de
bouger et cetera mais c'est vrai que on
a une situation aujourd'hui où on a
dévalorisé tous les métiers industriels
tous les métiers on va dire un peu
manuel mais qui aujourd'hui ont un
niveau de vie beaucoup plus élevé alors
moi je j'avais donné un conseil comme ça
qui qui me para intéressant c'est quand
on fait quand on prend les petits jeunes
savez en 4e on fait à l'école au collège
on leur dit qu'est-ce que tu vas faire
plus tard quand tu seras grand
évidemment ils savent pas donc on leur
dit moi je moi je vais boulanger ah non
boulanger non non ça non non tu vas
faire ça tu vas pourquoi tu tu es bon en
math c'est pas boulanger et alors si le
gosse il veut faire boulanger c'est
c'est c'est c'est sa passion il y a pas
de son métier moi j'aia pensé faire en
fait une sorte de de de grille en disant
voilà comment si dans dans tous les
métiers quel est le niveau de vie au
bout de 10 ans de métier et par tu sais
que en France au bout de les avocats je
crois qu'il y a quasiment la moitié des
avocats qui au bout de 10 ans ils ont
ils ont arrêté leur métier parce que
c'est trop fatiguant ça leur plaît
plusorte c'est énorme tu vois quel est
le niveau de vie et donc à partir de là
quand tu es jeune tu sais pas trop où
aller tu vois là tu tu vas ah si tu vois
que le taux de chômage des mecs qui ont
fait un bac + 5 en l'histoire de l'art
il est à 18 % je dis bon c'est peut-être
pas ça que que je vais faire j'aime
l'art mais ça sera quand quand tu vois
des profs souspayés qui bossent est-ce
que tu te rappelles le nom de ta prof de
français quand j'en plusieurs oui quand
tu vois qu'ils sont souspayés que les
conditions de travail sont dégueulasses
que ils vivent ils sont obligés
d'enseigner dans des dans des trucs tout
CC est-ce que ça motive pour faire prof
pour assurer le bonheur de la formation
nos générations futures moi je pense que
le problème si tu veux comme tu le sais
on a l'éducation nationale qui coûte la
plus cher du monde le problème c'est que
la moitié des dépenses c'est pas des
profs c'est les dépenses de de de
d'encadrement donc c'est ça le problème
bien sûr qu'il faut payer plus les profs
mais peut-être il y a des des postes
qu'on a pas forcément besoin donc c'est
nous non il faut constamment augmenter
tu regardes pas ce que tu augmentes et
et derrière il y a pas il y a pas
finalement de résultat tu comprends mais
j'ai aussi envie de dire peut-être un
truc un peu choquant sur les profs c'est
il faut le dire avec respect mais
évidemment évidemment j'adore les profs
j'étais prof moi mon premier métier
c'est prof prof d'économie à la fac donc
j'adore ce métier c'est un super métier
mais justement il faut avir moi je pense
que prof
ou ou enseignant quoi tu vois tout
simplement même maîtresse d'école tu
bref professeur des écoles maintenant et
C je pense c'est un sacerdoce bien sûr
ouais mais oui mais bon
je suis pas sûr que tous les profs pour
tous les profs c'est un sincerdos je
encore une fois je suis pas sûr et moi
je te donne un exemple j'avais un
économiste chez moi chez texis donc qui
avait qui donc était très bien payé
c'était mon numéro 2 pas donné son nom
mais peut-être sil écoute il se
reconnaîtra et j'aimais beaucoup bref et
quand j'ai quitté la texis donc il y
avait un il y avait un autre qui m'a bon
qui m'a remplacé bref et donc ça se
passait pas très bien et alors qu'il
qu'il est très très très bien payé il a
arrêté il a démiss
donc zéro indemnité il a démissionné
pour faire
prof parce que c'était sa passion et je
le et je le revois ENF on s'appelle
régulièrement on se voit de temps en
temps et il est heureux voilà je pense
que c'est ça qu'on a oublié c'estevient
sur la question sur le PIB tout à
l'heure c'est dire
que je pense qu'on a le concept de
bonheur il est galvodé c'estàd que et
c'est ça aujourd'hui moi je moi je pense
que prof c'est le plus beau métier du
monde et justement je parle HLM nous à
notre époque on avait un respect des
profs tu comprends on avait un un
respect des autorités au sens là Mo de
moins en moins dans les cités quand même
estce que c'est le prof qui t'aider à te
sortir de ton mais
ouais mais je je me rappelle tu c'est
une anecdote au collège il y avait un
prof le pauvre chéri et c'est un prof
d'italien parce moi j'ai fait de
l'italien et c'est son on savait pas
nous tu
vois c'était son premier cours tu vois
il est venit de voir son capè cétait son
premier les cours et je sais pas il nous
a pas inspiré tu vois il était un peu
mou bref et le pauvre on l'a enfin tout
le monde c'est collectif quoi tu vois on
l'a on l'a on l'a laminé quoi tu c'est
pas bien du tout to je je fais mon m
coup parce que moi j'ai c'était pas moi
le le le meneur dans l'équipe mais et je
me rappellerai toujours après donc le
cours d'après parce que tous les profs
sont venus nous voir les autres profs tu
vois qu'on avait et ave avec lui donc
ils nous ont dit voilà et puis le prof
il a pleuré quoi tu vois et on s'est dit
on a déconné tu vois et et et
aujourd'hui je suis pas sûr que ça ça
pourrait se passer de la même façon je
pense qu'il y a des profs qui se font
massacrés malheureusement en permanence
l'éducation nationale les profs ils
arrivent plus à recruter parce que les
gens veulent les mais mais donc ch tu
vois je pense que ils sont pas assez
payés non mais non mais on a il y a pas
que il y a pas que il y a pas que le
problème du paiement il y a le problème
du respect moi je pense que aujourd'hui
un prof quelqu'un qui va t'enseigner
quelque chose il il faut que ça ça donne
du respect tu on doit mais l'inverse
c'est vrai dire moi j'ai moi je j'ai
donné plein de cours et cetera donc je
pense qu'un élève enfin un étudiant il
sent quand c'est quand tu fais ce métier
par par vocation que c'est ton que c'est
ton truc tu fais ça avec les tripes et
et donc automatiquement le respect il
vient tu vois et donc si jamais il se
sent pas alors là ça peut être dangereux
tu vois donc donc c'est moi c'est pas un
métier facile mais ce que je dis par là
c'est que il faut
aujourd'hui le le problème de notre
société et pas qu'en France dans
beaucoup de pays c'est le respect et
donc je pense que pour avoir retrouver
ce respect il faut là j'ai je m'écarte
de mon côté économique hein il faut
tolérance zéro c'est-à-dire que ceux qui
font des voilà qui respectent pas et
cetera qui font des des trucs on les
punit là aujourd'hui il y a aucune
aucune aucune sanction donc on continue
bon il y a plein d'autres sujets qu'on
souhaitait aborder avec toi comme
l'intelligence artificielle la hyper
frequency trading tout un tas de choses
ou ça c'est ça c'est c'est c'est c'est
c'est l'avenir entre guillemets bien
entendu mais on en reparlera quand tu
reviendras j'ai une question Internet
avant de te demander trois bouquins
quelle est sa prospective pour les
années à venir qui a pardon quelle est
sa prospective pour les années qui
arrivent pour la France je te demande à
2 5 et 10 ans si tu es capable de faire
plus que c'est déjà bien ouais ouais
exactement non je pense que 10 ans c'est
très compliqué c'est faut être honnête
déjà 2 ans c'est énorme moi je fais mes
prévisionstipation anticipation j'en
fais à 5 ans mais bon c'est c'est c'est
c'est plus une tendance tu comprends
sinon mes clients en tout cas eux-mêmes
ils me demandent pas plus que 1 2 ans
parce qu'ils savent que ça bouge
tellement combien tu
gagnes ça dépend des
années je gagne bien ma vie je gagne
bien ma vie mais ça se dit plus
maintenant c'est ça le problème c'est
c'est alors j'ai j'ai mieux gagné ma vie
que qu'aujourd'hui parce que en fait si
tu veux quand j'ai eu 40 ans j'ai la
crise de la quarantaine tu vois donc je
me suis dit non mais pas pas en tout
bien tout tenonur c'estàd je pas divorcé
je suis resté marié et ouais ouais non
parce que des fois ça ça se B en
chaussette comme on dit mais mais c'est
vrai que je me suis tu dis je viens des
citer HLM j'ai travaillé toute ma vie
vraiment à fond à fond et mais j'ai pas
profité de la vie tu vois donc c'est tu
vois même maintenant tu vois donc j'ai
pas tu acheté une voiture non non pas du
tout non non moi j'adore voyager et je
trouve que c'est c'est un c'est un
enseignement si tu veux de la vie
exceptionnelle que tu vois dans le monde
entier tu vois comment les gens vivent
tu vois et ça bon je sais qu'and j'ai
pris l'avion j'ai un Bilon cardan pas
génial mais voilà je me suis dit faut
que et donc voilà donc je suis parti à
l'étranger même des fois avec ma femme
aussi ça bon on a et voilà et ça c'est
vrai que ça m'a donc c'est vrai que de
facto on m'a un peu moins vu ici donc
après tu les gens ils te voient moins
donc ils font moins appel à toi et
cetera voilà donc mais c'éit un choix c
un choix voilà donc voilà et mais donc
tout ça pour dire que donc mes
perspectives de 2 à 5
ans cette année donc j'ai à 0,5 % de
croissance en 2024 l'année prochaine tu
sais la France elle a une croissance
structurelle ça veut dire qu'il
s'obtient dans fonctionnement normal de
l'économie de 0,9 % de
croissance c'est très faible très faible
donc on pourra pas faire des miracles
donc si on a 1 % pendant les 3 années à
venir ça sera déjà énorme et donc le
seul problème moi qui m'embête c'est que
voilà on parle du PIB mais le chômage va
augmenter voilà ça je suis un peu embêté
parce que il est en train d'augmenter
déjà alors qu'on a pas encore vraiment
une vraie récession tu dramatique donc
ça ça c'est un conseil que je donne
également
d'amis si vous avez un boulot gardez-le
c'est a pas envie de de bouger tout de
suite maintenant attendez un peu voilà
donc c'est voilà c'est et tout va
dépendre également de la la politique
qu'on va faire d'un point de vue
budgétaire quoi est-ce qu'on va être
sérieux parce que si faut bien prendre
conscience que comme on l' dit tout à
l'heure si les taux d'intérêt augmentent
si si on est dégradé tout intérêt vont
augmenter et là on peut avoir une
récession durable c'està dire qu'on peut
avoir zéro pendant plusieurs années voir
du négatif est-ce que tu as trois
bouquins à conseiller à notre communauté
des des bouquins qui ont été importants
dans ta vie ah alors en fait moi moi un
bouquin qui a vraiment été très
important c'est j'en ai parlé tout à
l'heure c'est la théorie générale de
keines parce que c'est un livre
d'économie bon ça vrai qu'il date donc
des années des années 20 20 300 mais euh
mais il est enfin pour moi c'est l'
enfin il c'était il y a des gens comme
ça comme des on dirait des prophètes
c'estàd visionnair si tu veux et te sort
des phrases moi je le relis
régulièrement tu veux parce que en fait
c'est euh c'est euh c'est comme la Bible
tu vois je pourrais le rajouter j'avais
pas pensé je je oui oui je lis
régulièrement la Bible tu crois en Dieu
ah bien sûr est-ce que tu as un ami
imaginaire un ami imaginaire c'est Dieu
c'est ça que tu veux dire je sais pas si
un ami c'est c'est c'est c'est une force
tu veux force transcendantale
oui
ouis bien sûr enfin mais alors donc je
reviens sur les bouquins quand mêmeen
parler non non bien sûr non mais Mo je
j'ai rien à cacher tu vois ce que je
veux dire
donc oui donc théorie générale de Kens
ça c'est je le conseille vraiment à tous
les jeunes économistes parce que c'est
un très bon livre déjà bon si on peut
lire en anglais c'est mieux parce qu'on
a des fois la traduction il y a des donc
c'est mieux mais en français c'est bien
aussi hein parce qu'en fait ça montre
comment parce que lui il a vécu quand
même le crack de 29 tu vois donc ça
c'est ça c'est quand même c'est pas mal
tu vois donc la Bible ouais ouais je lis
la bible je lis la bible je je je trouve
c'est alors bon il régulièrement parce
qu'en fait c'est bah parce que je crois
en Dieu bien sûr mais mais c'est vrai
que c'est c'est au-delà de du fait de
croire en Dieu mais c'est je trouve que
c'est
manuel de propagande c'est ça non non
non non ça remet les idées en place tu
vois ce que je veux dire et et je trouve
c'est aussi important tu vois de de dire
que ça s'arrête pas là parce que si tu
dis ça s'arrête là bah finalement tu
peux faire toutes les conneries que tu
veux quoi tu vois tu vois donc je trouve
c'est c'est c'est aussi même pour nos
dirigeants tu vois peut-être qu'il
ferait moins de conneries s'il croyent
en Dieu je sais pas s'il croi en Dieu ou
pas c'est très touchant ce que tu dis là
c'est très touchant non mais c'est vrai
bon don mais moi si tu veux c'est c'est
une réalité c'estàd c'est moi je je suis
quelqu'un voilà je moi je pense que ce
que ce que m' appris mes parents si tu
veux c'est l'honnêteté et si je vais te
dire un truc moi j'aurais pu faire des
conneries quand on rest HLM tu t'es fait
taper sur les doigts je pense non non
jamais jamais tu t'es jamais fait choper
non j'ai jamais fait de conneries enfin
peut-être des petits trucs comme ça des
trucs mais mais il y avait des
tentations tu n'imagines même pas tes
grands-parents ils étaiit proche de toi
mais j'étais pas connu mon grand-père
est décdé quand j'avais 3 ans ma
grand-mère quand j'avais 5 ans donc je
j'ai j'ai pas beaucoup de souvenir d'eux
quoi tu vois mais c'est vrai que si tu
veux moi ils m'ont toujours appris
l'honnêteté tu vois c'està dire voilà
on volera on vole jamais quoi tu vois il
faut pas voler tu vois et c'est vrai que
j'ai des copains qui étent avec moi qui
ont mal tourné parce que en fait ça pr
des CLM tuas tu as de la des fois on
fout rien tu vois donc tu as de la
tentation tu fais une connerie tu as un
Casio du Cher tu es mort donc il faut
surtout pas faire ta première connerie
voilà et c'est vrai que j'avais toujours
mes parents toujours me dis je peux pas
leur faire ça ils sont tellement ils
sacrifi tellement pour moi je peux pas
leur faire ça et donc ça ça m'a je pense
ça m'a protégé ça m ça m'a un peu sauvé
et aujourd'hui si tu veux quand je vois
des quand je vois des voleurs des gens
qui font des arnaques
c'est pour moi c'est insupportable et
lesé colle blanc qui font des AR ah ça
c'est insupportable c'est pour ça que je
t'ai dis pour moi même dans la finance
tu veux des des mec qui des fois tu vois
te font de l'argent avec de l'argent en
mentant par exemple pour moi c'est
inacceptable trafique le
riborib ouais aussi c'est pareil c'est
inacceptable tu vois ce que dire bon tu
vois la finance Tentreprise tu vois tu
vas financer des entreprises tu vas
financer l'état même tu vas tu vas faire
de la gestion tu vas aider aux gens à
mieux gérer leur portefeuille et ce ça
c'est beau ça c'est noble tu comprends
mais euh voilà faire des magouilles pour
moi c'est et donc donc si j'en ai des
noms je pourrais t'en citer des gens
connus et cetera mais bon ça pour moi
c'est inacceptable insupportable deuxème
livre alors euh deuxè ah oui il y a un
livre qui m'a marqué je sais pas
pourquoi euh c'est euh c'est le père
gorio de Balzac je l'ai lu à l'école
quand j'étais petit quand j'étais jeune
quoi je sais pas quel âge j'avais et je
trouve qu'il est donc je sais pas che
ceux que tu l'as lu mais ils ont SVEC
rastigac et cetera et c'était un peu mon
mon histoire c'estàd c'estis le mec tu
vois un mec qui vient bon lui il vit de
la campagne c'est pareil tu vois et puis
je me suis un peu identifié à lui
c'estàd un mec bon alors ça se passe mal
parce qu'à la fin il fait des bêtises
mais bon mais c'était un peu ça si tu
veux et moi justement j'ai réussi à
éviter de faire des des bêtises et j'ai
gardé le cap de Français qui t'avait
demandé de lire le père oui oui oui bien
sûr bien et c'est vrai que c'est un
livre c'est un livre c'est un livre qui
m'a c'est un livre qui m'a qui m'a
marqué qui m'a marqué parce que c'était
voilà
c'était tu me demandes j'ai pas préparé
donc c'est pour voilà je sors là ça
m'est sorti ça m'est sorti comme ça quoi
voilà ça m'est sorti comme ça alors un
trème on va on va rester peut-être
qu'est-ce que je pourrais te dire
cherche j'en ai quand même pas mal même
si je suis pas un grand qu'est- c'est
que je pourrais dire là il y a un truc
qui me vient ah oui un un truc bon qui
est sorti en film qui je trouve un livre
formidable le nom de la rose par tu qui
est sorti enfins en on fait un film avec
le film c'est ch conneries ah mais ce
c'est un c'est un fil moi j'aime bien
aussi j'aime bien les romans policiers
tuaim bien tuaim bien le le moine qui
parle toutes les langues c'est ça quiche
les doouis j'aime bien le j'aime bien
les roman policier parce que je trouve
bien fait he pas tous hein même VO bon
c'est c'est pas très maisis les Arlan
Coban trucs comme ça bon ça c'est plus
récent bon je devrais pas dire je dis ça
mais mais c'est sympa et donc c'est V
que le nom de la rose c'est un livre
aussi qui m'a marqué et après qui a été
fait en film d'ailleurs je trouve que le
film était était bien et euh on Berto
exactement et c'est vrai que voilà alors
euh comment dire voilà j'aime bien
également les les livres policiers voilà
quand tu as une intrigue voilà un
conseil pour les jeunes générations
Marc donc un conseil j'en ai plusieurs
l'honnêteté d'abord le le plus important
c'est l'honnêteté de le travail le gros
problème qu'on a aujourd'hui c'est que
la valeur travail é égal V alors est-ce
que c'est un effet coronavirus 35 he ça
peut-être télétravail tout ça moi tu
veux j'ai j'ai j'ai toujours voulu
inculquer ça à mes enfants ils m'ont ont
toujours vu beaucoup travailler parce et
je pense c'est important et pour moi le
travail moi j'ai eu la chance c'est vrai
de faire un métier que j'adore donc pour
moi c'est pas du travail c'est vrai que
c'est c'est de la passion donc je
travaille beaucoup mais c'est pour moi
c'est pas vrai c'est pas un travail ça
me fatigue pas tu vois ça me fait kiffer
tu vois et c'est vrai que quand j'ai vu
ma crise de la quarantaine donc à un
moment je tu vois je je me rappelle
j'étais
dans sur une plage m plus très belle
plage et cetera et je voilà c'était très
beau puis je me suis dit ça me manque
quand même de de d'aller voir mes
clients d'aller faire des conférences tu
vois je me suis dit c'est vrai que c'est
c'est super de kiffer mais bon ben ok
une fois que tu as fait une plage 10
plages 30 plages bon ok donc c'est
important donc le travail il y a pas
plus et surtout de se valoriser dans le
travail ça c'est très important et voilà
et puis euh on a eu même on a eu le même
souci euh mais Marc Hulman est venu nous
sortir de la plage ah voilà désolé de
t'avoir coupéà tu veux rajouter quelque
chose le Conseil voilà donc l'honnêteté
le le travail et j'ai envie dire et
surtout la persévérance ça veut dire
bien comprendre que que les crises sont
toujours des phases d'opportunité il
faut pas avoir peur des crises moi ça me
gêne quand les gens me disent oui ou
vous dites que des crises non non mais
c'est pas grave une crise c'est pas
grave ça peut arriver c'est comme le
corps humain des fois il y a des crises
pourtant sortir par le haut de ces
crises et donc c'est vrai que c'est pas
toujours facile mais on peut toujours
s'en sortir voilà moi je je viens d'
citer HLM j'ai le sens de m'en sortir et
je regrette pas c HLM ça m'a beaucoup
appris et j'aimerais bien que ça serait
bien que nos dirigeants justement ils
aient fait quelques stages dans mais des
vrais stages tu vois en
intégrationir B
j'ai je viens de recevoir un un dernier
un dernier message sur notre chat
privé je voudrais que tu lui tu lui
répondre est-ce qu'il pourrait est-ce
qu'il aurait un mot pour les personnes
seules pauvres et sans réseau comment on
s'en sort quand on a même plus le luxe
de l'espoir
ouais ça c'est horrible c'est tu vois je
suis venu en métro là je suis venu en
métro et donc dans le métro parisien
malheureusement à chaque fois il il y a
des gens qui font la manche et des gens
dans de notre âge quoi tu vois c'est des
gens de de mon âge quoi c'estd qui ont 5
50 ans et cetera donc to c'est et tu
vois que c'est des gens il te disent le
monsieur il disait voilà il a perdu son
boulot il a perdu il a divorcé il tu te
rends compte comment la déchéance ça
peut arriver très vite et le monsieur
disait donnez-moi un centime tu vois ce
que je veux dire c'est horrible donc
alors je lui ai donné un peu plus
j'avais pas un centime et tu pe donner à
tout le monde non plus c'est sûr mais ce
que je dire par là c'est que il faut
euh il faut garder l'espoir la foi il y
a rien de pire moi ça m'est arrivé de
dans ma vie un moment de de perdre la
foi c'est horrible c'est horrible donc
je le souhaite à personne don il faut
garder il faut garder la la foi et la
force aussi de dire qu'on peut y arriver
et tu vois c'est là où on se dit quand
même il y a un problème on a un pays où
tu as 58,5 % du PIB de dépenses
publiques 11 % du PIB de dette publique
et tu as des personnes qui ont qui sont
qui arrivent à à ce stade-là des des
gens qui ont vécu en France qui ont fait
leur vie en France j'imagine enfin bon
qui ont travaillé et cetera je dis il y
a un problème tu vois donc donc ça ça
veut dire que c'est pas un problème de
moyens mais d'allocation de ces moyens
tu vois et surtout il faut je pense
qu'il faut il faut pas arriver justement
faut tout faire pour arriver d'en
arriver là parce que ça peut ça peut
arrê ça peut aller très vite donc il
faut toujours se je pense he garder cet
espoir cette force c'est pas facile hein
il faut garder effectivement il faut
garder la force moi je donne un exemple
personnel je me rappelle mon père me
raconter cette histoire lui c'est un
rapatri d'Algérie donc donc il en 62
donc l'Algérie est devenue indépendant
donc ils ont viré tous les Français
enfin les Français sont venus parce
qu'ils pouvaient pas rester quoi bref
ENF une grande majorité d'entre eux
sinon il se faisaent tué et et mon père
m'a raconté ça ça me choquait parce que
tu sais quand tu es petit tu vois ton
père comme un héros quoi tu vois et et
mon père il me disait que donc il est
arrivé c'était c'était en 62 pourant il
y avait le plein emploi tu vois à
l'époque mais il il trouvait pas de
boulot parce que tu voison cétait très
mal perçu et cetera la rapatrie de
l'Algérie bref et et il m'a dit à un
moment il était dans le
métro pas s'est posé la question tu vois
moi j'étais pas encore né parce que je
suis en 70 tu vois et c'est pas possible
que tu pensé à un truc pareil tu vois
donc je me suis dit tu vois ça peut
arriver à tout le monde tu comprends bon
alors heureusement bon après il a pu il
a trouvé du boulot tout ça mais voilà il
faut pas en arriver là c'est il faut il
faut garder cette image et il me donner
aussi une image euh de ENF pourquoi je
raconte ça maintenant mais c'est c'est
mon grand-père qui lui raconter ça cette
histoire et que un jour il il voyait
quelqu'un qui euh qui était très pauvre
euh je sais pas si c'est une histoire
vraie euh et et donc qui euh donc il dit
bon je vais faire je vais manger un plat
de lentille et puis après je me suicide
et donc il a mangé son plat de lentille
dans les L ou ou de de Poischich donc tu
tu tu tu tu lâches les peaux quoi tu tu
jettes les peaux quoi tu vois et il se
retourne et il voit quelqu'un qui ramass
masse les peaux pour les
manger tu vois et et et ça le donnait ça
leur donnait la pêche tu vois tu dis qu'
a toujours pire c'est ça voilà c'est
dire tu et donc c'est alors voilà il
faut pas en arriver là et surtout VO il
faut il faut garder il faut garder au
maximum l'espoir et j'espère que
justement un jour la France va retrouver
son sa force va retrouver son son
apparat quoi ça ça et pour éviter qu'on
a qu'on en arrive là quoi parce que
c'est sûr que quand tu vois ça ce qui se
passe que ça se passe chez nous he c'est
c'est dis colig dans la musique des la
chanson des Restos du cœur tu ça arrive
ici aujourd'hui c'est dans les années 80
tu imagines et donc tu te dis il y a un
problème parce que on a mis quand même
des moyens énormes tu vois et il y a
toujours effectivement des gens qui qui
arrivent à ce niveau donc voilà je je je
souhaite de garder l'espoir et de de
J'espère de tout cœur qu'il s'en sortira
Marc toati merci avec plaisir avec
plaisir merci à vous et bonne
continuation
[Musique]